Hey, so right off the bat, I'm not sure if you guys are aware of this listener, you too. This is the start of our fourth year. We have completed three years as of yesterday. Right. Today is the first episode of our fourth year. So it's our birthday, third year birthday. Sorry.
嘿，首先，我不知道各位听众知不知道，你们也是。这是我们第四年的开始。截至昨天，我们已经走过了三年。对吧。今天是第四年的第一集。所以今天是我们的生日，三周年生日。抱歉。
I mean, we look just pretty humble. We look terrible for three years old, but we feel good. We feel young. And listen, I'm reading in the four. And we wouldn't be in our fourth year. If it wasn't for you guys, thank you very much for listening and caring and giving a poop about anything we have to say for God.
我的意思是，我们看起来挺谦虚的。三岁的小孩看起来真够呛，但我们感觉很好。我们觉得自己还年轻。听着，我正在读第四年。如果不是因为你们，我们也不会迎来第四年。非常感谢你们的收听、关心，以及对我们说的任何废话都那么在乎，老天爷啊。
Thanks for not getting sick of Will and Sean yet. I mean, it's just, it's surprising. It's surprising. You're still here. Yeah. Maybe a little thanks to our team. Oh, yeah. Oh, shit.
谢谢你们还没对威尔和肖恩感到厌烦。我的意思是，这简直，太令人惊奇了。太令人惊奇了。你们居然还在。是的。也许这要稍微感谢一下我们的团队。哦，对了。哦，见鬼。
And then thanks to our, and Bennett wanted me to mention thanks to the team, you know, who does it? Bennett and Rob and Michael, Bennett Barbarco and Robert Arnett. Arnett. Arnett. Arnett. And Michael Terry, who without them, well, we'd still make it happen to me.
然后感谢我们的，班纳特想让我提一下，感谢团队，你知道的，是谁在做这些？班纳特、罗布和迈克尔，班纳特·巴尔巴科和罗伯特·阿内特。阿内特。阿内特。阿内特。还有迈克尔·特里，没有他们，好吧，我们还是能把事情搞定，对我来说。
We would just be bad. Our wings would not flap as fast. We would not fly as high. We just want to be good. We do it, but it would just, it would suck. That's certainly true. They make our lives better. And I also want to say shout out to the woman out there who comments on one of our posts
我们只会变得很糟。我们的翅膀不会扇动得那么快。我们不会飞得那么高。我们只想变好。我们能做到，但那感觉会糟透了。这绝对是真的。他们让我们的生活变得更好。我还想对外面那个在我们的一个帖子下留言的女士喊话
and said, uh, our net will just shut up. And, uh, and just say, you're heard. Anyway, happy birthday. Happy birthday. Happy birthday to us and to you guys and all of the smarties out there. Guys, yeah, here we are yep and it's a it's a podcast yeah let's get podcasting but wait and so yeah exactly so how do we get the podcasting to do it do it stretching or anything a vocal exercises yeah I'll do like. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it.
并且说，呃，阿内特，你闭嘴吧。然后，呃，只想说，你们的声音被听到了。不管怎样，生日快乐。生日快乐。祝我们、你们以及所有聪明人生日快乐。伙计们，是的，我们在这，是的，这是一个播客，是的，让我们开始做播客吧，但是等等，所以，是的，没错，那我们怎么做播客呢？做这个，做那个，拉伸还是别的什么？发声练习？是的，我会这样。我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。
I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it.
我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。
I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. I'll do it. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Here comes Jay. Here comes Jason. Uh oh, everybody be nervous. What do you be nervous? What are you wearing? I'm wearing, it looks like a 12-year-old shirt with a... What's happening? Listen, he's playing golf today.
我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。我会的。聪明蛋。聪明蛋。聪明蛋。聪明蛋。聪明蛋。杰伊来了。杰森来了。哦，天哪，大家都紧张起来。你紧张什么？你穿着什么？我穿着，看起来像一件12岁小孩穿的衬衫，带着……发生什么事了？听着，他今天要打高尔夫。
And with a long sleeve on? Well, that's... And it's gonna be warm out, dude. UV protection. Okay, I'm trying to be smart with the sun. And I'm also trying to be stylish at the same time. I've got on G4 here. You can't go wrong with that.
还穿着长袖？好吧，那是……而且外面会很热，老兄。防紫外线。好吧，我只是想在防晒方面聪明一点。而且我也想同时保持时尚。我穿了G4的衣服。穿这个绝对不会出错。
I give you a little fashion forward, you know. It's just forward towards. Careful. I know. I know. Okay. And the hair. And the hair is you can't pull it off.
我让你体验一点走在时尚前沿的感觉，你知道的。也就是朝着前方。小心点。我知道。我知道。好吧。还有发型。还有发型，你可驾驭不了。
I wear foot joy, which is what I'm telling you. And I'm tidalist. I wear the heritage brands. Uh-huh. And you can't pull that off. You can't pull off a heritage brand. Oh. It's not in your DNA.
我穿的是FootJoy，我跟你说过的那种。我是Titleist的粉丝。我穿的是传统品牌。嗯哼。而你驾驭不了这个。你驾驭不了传统品牌。哦。这不在你的基因里。
Hey, you know, speaking of DNA, you know what today is, Jay, you know I talked about with you last night, but Sean, you're going to be excited. I've had to have coffee with no cream this morning. And, oh. Wait, now, did you start? What do you mean? Well, I started in a couple hours. Today, I got my first ever colonoscopy tomorrow.
嘿，你知道的，说到基因，你知道今天是什么日子吗，杰伊，你知道我昨晚跟你说过，不过肖恩，你一定会很兴奋的。我今天早上喝了不加奶精的咖啡。然后，哦。等等，现在，你开始了吗？你什么意思？好吧，我几个小时后就开始。今天，我明天要去做人生的第一次肠镜检查。
Oh, so you can't do, I say. I can't eat anything. Wait, that's tomorrow. So you're doing a cleanse today. Yeah. Are you can't do, I say, can't eat anything. Wait, that's tomorrow. So you're doing a cleanse today. Yeah. Are you starving? Yeah, I'm starving in a chicken broth. I really, I've done this,
哦，所以你不能做，我说。我什么也不能吃。等等，那是明天。所以你今天在做肠道清洁。是的。你饿不饿？是的，我饿得只能喝鸡汤。我真的，我已经做过这个了，
I've done this like three, four times. Why they're making you do it in the middle of the day. Three four times? Yeah, well, I had a situation back in that, when I was 30. Yeah, no, I was with you. I was with you. I was with you. You were 34.
我已经做过三、四次了。为什么他们让你在白天做这个。三四次？是的，好吧，那是以前的情况，当我30岁的时候。对，没错，我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。我跟你在一起。你当时34岁。
I think you triggered it. But Jason and I were doing a scene from rest of them. We were in a fight scene. And all of a sudden he got, he went like white as a sheet. Like he was just exhausted. I just couldn't go any fight. I mean, you know, wheels of, you know, he's like wrestling, like wrestling a boa, you know,
我想是你诱发的。但当时杰森和我正在重现发展受阻（Arrested Development）里的一个场景。我们正在拍一场打斗戏。突然间他变得，他的脸色变得像纸一样白。就像他精疲力竭了一样。我简直打不动了。我的意思是，你知道的，威尔，你知道的，他就像在摔跤，就像在跟一条蟒蛇摔跤，你知道，
that it's going to take some energy out of you. And Sean, he tried to wrestle me on the lake. The frozen lake and was going to die. Oh yeah. Well, and the funny of this fight was supposedly that it just went on and on and on and on. That was the joke. And we did have to do it for a long time.
那会消耗你不少体力。肖恩，他试图在湖面上和我摔跤。结冰的湖面，差点就没命了。哦，是的。好吧，这场打斗最搞笑的地方在于，它据说没完没了，一直打，一直打，一直打。这就是个笑话。而且我们确实拍了很长时间。
Yeah. And I was like, I shouldn't be this tired. I'm not this out of shape. And so I went and saw a doctor and I'm like, I shouldn't be this tired. I'm not this out of shape. And so I went and saw a doctor and I'm like, oh, you're battling something. Is it turned out to be something in my GI? So anyway, they should only have you do this, like starting at like 6 p.m.
是的。当时我想，我不应该这么累。我没有这么缺乏锻炼。于是我去看医生，我说，我不应该这么累。我没有这么缺乏锻炼。于是我去看医生，我说，哦，你身体出毛病了。结果查出来是我的消化系统有问题。不管怎样，他们应该让你从晚上6点左右开始做这个。
So you're on the throne for a few hours, you go to bed, you wake up, and you do your procedure. But they have two options, right? You could go five in the morning or like it. I'm going five in the morning. Yeah. Oh God, that in the morning. Yeah. Oh God. You should be able to eat all day, I think,
这样你在马桶上坐几个小时，然后去睡觉，醒来就可以去做手术了。但他们有两种选择，对吧？你可以选早上五点或者别的。我选的是早上五点。是的。哦天哪，大清早的。是的。哦天哪。我觉得你应该一整天都能吃东西，
and then clean out at night. They claim no. They gave me explicit instructions. Starting this morning, do not eat anything. Only have bone broth. I should call Gwyneth. It was to her bone broth, actually. Could you start eliminating it? I have not. No, brother actually. Did you start eliminating it?
然后晚上再做清洁。他们说不行。他们给了我明确的指令。从今天早上开始，什么都不要吃。只能喝骨头汤。我应该给格温妮丝打个电话。实际上这正是她的骨头汤。你能开始戒掉它吗？我没有。不，其实是骨头汤。你开始戒掉它了吗？
I have not. No, thank you. They also said that they now do the procedure in a big shower. They have an operating room that's also double as a shower. Is it the Bateman? Is it the Bateman? It's the new Bateman wing at Cedars. Cedars can clean as you go. Maybe you call it. Ask a bee's in the shower right now. Everybody's in a bathing suit. It's kind of hot. Sean, if you, oh yeah, no, you are, yes, you get the famous story about, you told them to leave your, your, your, your rear door alone. You said don't put my ass all right before you went in.
我没有。不用了，谢谢。他们还说他们现在在一个大淋浴间里做手术。他们有一个手术室，同时也是一个淋浴间。是巴特曼（Bateman）手术室吗？是巴特曼手术室吗？那是锡安山医疗中心（Cedars）新建的巴特曼侧翼。锡安山医疗中心可以边做边清洗。也许你该打电话问问。现在大家都在淋浴间里吗？每个人都穿着泳衣。感觉有点辣。肖恩，如果你，哦对了，不，你是，是的，你有一个著名的故事，关于你告诉他们离你的，你的，你的，你的后门远一点。你进去之前说过别碰我的屁股。
But wait a minute. I talked to a guy yesterday who had 35. Wow. He's that. He's a little bit of a fetish. yesterday who had 35. Wow. He's that. He's like a little bit of a fat. What do you mean, 35? He said 35, Colin Oscarbees.
但等一下。我昨天跟一个做过35次的人聊过。哇。他是那种。他有点这方面的特殊癖好。昨天跟一个做过35次的人聊过。哇。他是那种。他有点像有那种癖好。你什么意思，35次？他说他做过35次肠镜检查。
That sounds like a, he had a kitchen, little shop of horrors. Right. When the boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
听起来像是个，他家里就像恐怖小店（Little Shop of Horrors）一样。对当砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom Remember that there was an episode of Arrest the development too. I know everybody's like, stop mentioning Arrest the development, but where the process character became addicted to the side effects of a drug, wasn't that? Well, I know you got a hair transplant and the hair transplant rejected the body instead of the body rejecting the hair transplant.
记得《发展受阻》里也有一集是这样的吗？我知道大家可能会说，别再提《发展受阻》了，但剧中的那个角色对某种药物的副作用上瘾了，不是吗？好吧，我知道你做了植发，结果身体排斥的不是植发，而是植发排斥了身体。
So his hair just kept growing more and more and more luxurious and his body was just atrophying. But he didn't want to reverse it because the hair was so beautiful. So he was willing to die. I remember him saying something about he used the word shunt at some point. Anyway, so, but tomorrow I'm expecting to be like a little thin 20 pound. Yeah, yeah, I can't do a lot of selfies tomorrow. When that when that bite comes out of your colon, that'll eliminate about nine pounds. You're going to be like a great white shark. They're going to cut you open. There's going to be stuff in there, Willie. Do you know how much ice cream they're going to find in there?
所以他的头发不断地生长，变得越来越浓密，而他的身体却在不断萎缩。但他不想逆转这个过程，因为头发实在是太漂亮了。所以他宁愿死。我记得他不知什么时候用过“分流”（shunt）这个词。不管怎样，所以，但明天我预计自己会像一个轻了20磅的小瘦子。是的，是的，我明天拍不了太多自拍。当那个，当那个结肠镜拔出来的时候，那能减掉大约九磅。你会变得像一条大白鲨。他们会把你切开。里面会有东西的，威利。你知道他们在里面能找到多少冰淇淋吗？
I know me too, my God. Is that your, is that your, well, who are you talking to the other night? It's a pine of ice cream every night. Other than John. Oh, no, Will's Jimmy. Does he a pint of ice cream every night? A pint of ice cream every night. He's a lean man. He's a thin man. Well, Sean, you're pretty lean and you you eat like you're going to the chair. Yeah, I do. I do have ice cream almost every night, almost every night. I do, I do, I go through phases where I'll have, but I lose it the next day. Yeah.
我知道我也是，天哪。那是你的，那是你的，嗯，你前天晚上跟谁聊天来着？每天晚上吃一品脱冰淇淋。除了约翰。哦，不，威尔的吉米。他每天晚上吃一品脱冰淇淋吗？每天晚上吃一品脱冰淇淋。他是个精瘦的男人。他是个瘦削的男人。好吧，肖恩，你挺精瘦的，而且你吃东西的样子就像要上电椅一样。对，我确实是。我几乎每天晚上都吃冰淇淋，几乎每天晚上。我确实吃，我有时会经历一段时间天天吃，但我第二天就能把它消耗掉。是的。
Well, we found it. You see what you found it again. Well, my cookie-paste. If you're looking for it, it's on your face. Okay, let's get into our guest. Wow. Guys, I've really upped my game today in the Cure Guest. This is my guest.
好吧，我们找到了。你看你又把它找出来了。好吧，我的曲奇酱。如果你在找它，它就在你的脸上。好了，让我们进入正题，欢迎我们的嘉宾。哇。伙计们，今天我在请嘉宾这方面真的是下血本了。这就是我的嘉宾。
I don't know, I'm not even cool enough game today in the Cure Department. This is my guest. I don't know. I'm not even cool enough to ask him the dumb questions I have. You've upped your game to the Cure Department. Got it. Wait, this is something you need to ask the dumb questions. By the way, you can just go with the flow. No, I know, but I come prepared with some dumb questions. Did you write the central?
我甚至不知道，我甚至不够酷，问不出我那些愚蠢的问题。你在嘉宾部门真是下足了功夫了。明白了。等等，这是你需要问蠢问题的地方。顺便说一句，你大可以随性一点。不，我知道，但我准备了一些愚蠢的问题。你写了中心内容吗？
That's rare for you. This must be somebody you have respect for. I did write a little bit of it. Yes, you write yours. I do. Yeah, Willie just likes to kind of minor freestyle. Mine fun. Today, guys, we know him as a superhero and Hollywood heartthrob.
这可真少见。这一定是你非常尊重的人。我确实写了一小部分。是的，你写了你自己的。我写了。是的，威利比较喜欢即兴发挥。我的很有趣。今天，伙计们，我们都知道他是一个超级英雄和好莱坞万人迷。
His lip sync battle mashup of Gene Kelly and Rihanna is still one of the most talked about and watched celebrity lip syncs of all time. One of the paltryl famously doesn't remember being in a movie with him. And before he entered the Marvel universe, he was performing ballet every night in the West End. It's the infectious, lovable Tom Holland. Wow. And I go, I use my morning Tom. Tom, can I call you Tommy?
他模仿吉恩·凯利和蕾哈娜的对口型假唱混搭秀，至今仍是史上讨论度最高、观看人数最多的名人假唱之一。帕特尔家族著名的不记得曾和他一起拍过电影。在进入漫威宇宙之前，他每晚都在西区（West End）表演芭蕾舞。他就是充满感染力、人见人爱的汤姆·赫兰德。哇。然后我说，我用我早晨的嗓音说，汤姆，我能叫你汤米吗？
Of course you can. Tommy, you've been on my list for like two years, and I've been trying to get you to come on the show. This is so exciting for me. You almost said a year, and then you doubled it. Yeah, I was a year, and then I remembered. It's been like two years. Wait, now Tom, you're a golfer.
当然可以。汤米，你在我的名单上已经呆了大约两年了，我一直想请你来节目。这让我太兴奋了。你刚才差点说了一年，然后你又把它翻倍了。对，我先说了一年，然后我想起来了。其实已经有两年了。等等，现在汤姆，你是个高尔夫球手。
I'm mad at you. What do you think about this beautiful G4 shirt I've done in New York? It's pink, it's got something. Something G4. Well, that's a great company. I want to give this a little surprise. I'm not sure about the underlayer.
我生你的气。你觉得我在纽约穿的这件漂亮的G4衬衫怎么样？它是粉红色的，上面有点图案。带有G4标志的某种东西。好吧，那是个伟大的公司。我想给你一个小惊喜。我不太确定里面的内搭。
Yeah, but there's Son out here. I'm not sure about the underlayer. Yeah, but if you're son out here, let him talk. I tell you what, actually, Jason, my brother Harry, we were shooting a movie in Atlanta, I think probably at the same time. He was at the Bobby Jones driving range and saw you there. We were going to go play golf, I think. And he said to me, I said, did you say hello? And he said, no, he's nursing a pretty intense slice right now. I didn't feel like it was the right time to go.
是的，但这里有阳光。我不太确定里面的内搭。是的，但如果你这有阳光，让他说吧。我跟你说，其实，杰森，我弟弟哈利，我们在亚特兰大拍一部电影，大概是在同一时间。他在鲍比·琼斯练习场看到了你。我们当时正要去打高尔夫，我想。他对我说，我说，你打招呼了吗？他说，没有，他现在正打出相当厉害的右曲球（slice）。我觉得这不是过去打扰的好时机。
I would have struck him with my butt with my club. Just ripping slices off the teeth. Tom, I heard that by the way, great to meet you, man. And I heard from a mutual friend that we have actually that you are a great golfer. And he claims that you're like a two. Can you confirm that? I'm not two. No, I'm a four. Oh, yeah. But I played this weekend. I just went up and stayed to play golf to get away from the city and enjoy some golf. I was one over the front nine with
我会用我的球杆打烂他的屁股。开球就把球削飞。汤姆，我听说，很高兴认识你，伙计。我从我们共同的一个朋友那里听说，其实你是个很棒的高尔夫球手。他声称你的水平大概是2。你能证实一下吗？我不是2。不，我是4。哦，是的。但我这个周末去打了。我专门去打高尔夫，为了远离城市，享受一下高尔夫。前九洞我打出了低于标准杆1杆的好成绩，
like some serious golf being played and 13 over the back nine completely. Well, because you're working too much. You need to be a, be a less good actor and you won't get hired. You know what they say? They say if you're shooting over 80, you have no business playing golf, and if you shoot under 80, you have no business. So. Let me ask you something. I don't know anything you're talking about.
有一些非常棒的击球，而后九洞完全打出了高于标准杆13杆。好吧，那是因为你工作太忙了。你需要做个水平没那么高的演员，这样你就不会总接到片约了。你知道他们怎么说吗？他们说如果你打出超过80杆，你根本不配打高尔夫；如果你打出低于80杆，你更不配。所以。让我问你个问题。我根本听不懂你在说什么。
What would my number be? 100. Well, probably. Yeah, probably. I bet you, a guy who probably have never played before, you get a triple bogey on every hall, so that's three times 18 is, what, 56? 56 on top is, yeah, that's about 130.
我的水平是多少？100。好吧，可能吧。是的，可能吧。我敢打赌，一个可能从来没玩过高尔夫的人，你在每个洞都会打出三柏忌，所以这就是3乘18，是多少，56？上面再加上56，是的，大概是130。
And so, and you're a four. I'm a four, but I'm a loose four. You know, I couldn't consider myself to be a true four. I just had some lessons. I had lessons. I'm a loose one, 30. How did you get so good at golf? You're so young, doesn't it?
所以，你是4。我是4，但我是一个水货4。你知道，我不能认为自己是一个真正的4。我刚刚上了几节课。我上过课。我是一个水货130。你怎么把高尔夫打得这么好？你这么年轻，不是吗？
It takes a lifetime to become a four, doesn't it? I think I just played as a kid. My dad was really into it. It's the thing that I've always done with my dad that we bonded over, that I've always had a lot of fun. And then I gave up for a long time when I just thought it was boring as a kid. I just couldn't get into it.
要花一辈子才能练到4级水平，不是吗？我想我小时候就一直在玩。我爸爸非常喜欢它。这是我和我爸爸一直以来一起做的事，我们通过这个维系感情，我一直觉得很有趣。然后我放弃了很长一段时间，因为我小时候觉得它太无聊了。我实在提不起兴趣。
And then I was on set of Spider-Man 2. And I was outside. I ended up speaking to one of the chippies on set who was building some sort of spaceship or something. And he ended up playing golf. We were shooting out of golf course. We all ended up going out playing golf. And we all became best going out playing golf and
然后我当时在《蜘蛛侠2》的片场。我在外面。我最后跟片场的一个木工聊了起来，他当时在造某种飞船之类的东西。结果他也打高尔夫。我们当时在一个高尔夫球场拍戏。我们最后都去打高尔夫了，我们所有人都变成了去打高尔夫的，
we all became best friends. I have a collection of like 10 people. If I'm back in London, I play every single day. And they're all, I mean, they're like plus one plus two, like proper, proper golfers. Yeah. So I'm constantly chasing them. But I had some lessons the other day with this guy who's fantastic. And I know that what he's saying will ultimately make me a better player, but right now I'm fucked. Like literally I'm missing both ways, fan it, thin and it, missing parts, it's tough out there right now. Yeah, yeah.
我们所有人都成了最好的朋友。我有一群大概10个人的朋友。如果我回伦敦，我每天都去打。而且他们，我的意思是，他们都是加1加2的水平，是真正的高手。所以我在拼命追赶他们。但我前几天跟一个非常棒的教练上了一些课。我知道他说的话最终会让我成为一个更好的球员，但现在我彻底搞砸了。真的，我现在两边都在失误，要么打厚（fat），要么打薄（thin），状况百出，现在日子不好过啊。是的，是的。
I feel you after now. Well, you're hitting all the stuff I wanted to talk about. Well, your questions are gone. I guess not. Oh, I thought you were going to say something like, well, you're hitting it out of the park with your career, Mr. Holland. Let me I thought you're gonna say something like well, you're hitting it out of the park with your career, Mr. Holland. Let me talk to you about that. Well, that would have been better. By the way, happy belated birthday. Thank you. June 1st. June 1st. June 1st. Well, how old is that make you?
我现在能体会你的感受了。好吧，你聊的正好都是我想聊的话题。好吧，你的问题全没了。看来没有。哦，我还以为你会说类似“你在事业上真是大获成功，赫兰德先生”这样的话呢。让我，我还以为你会说类似“你在事业上真是大获成功，赫兰德先生。让我跟你聊聊这个”呢。好吧，那样会更好。顺便说一句，祝你迟来的生日快乐。谢谢。6月1日。6月1日。6月1日。好吧，那说明你多大了？
27, my 27. Good. Good for you. Yeah. Do you guys remember what were you doing at 27, Willie? Why wasn't crushing it. I tell you that much. Sean, I got Will and Grace at 27. Did you really? Yeah, no, you go. I loved Will and Grace. I was always watching that my mom and I when I was a kid. Fuck me. I was going to say it was. I thought you were too young to know what that was. No, absolutely not. I love that show. You were born in Kingston upon Tames, is that I, is that? Or Tames, yeah.
27岁，我27岁了。很好。真为你高兴。是的。你们还记得你们27岁的时候在做什么吗，威利？我当时可没有混得风生水起。我只能这么说。肖恩，我27岁的时候演了《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）。真的吗？是的，不，你说。我很喜欢《威尔和格蕾丝》。我小时候总是和我妈妈一起看。操。我本来想说的是。我以为你太年轻了，根本不知道那是什么。不，绝对没有。我很喜欢那个节目。你是出生在泰晤士河畔金斯敦（Kingston upon Thames）吗，我，是吗？泰晤士河畔，是的。
The River Tames, yeah. Which I'm an idiot. West London, right? Correct. And you still live there? I do, yes. And who's in your house? In my house is me, my two brothers,
泰晤士河，是的。我真是个笨蛋。伦敦西部，对吧？没错。你还住在那里吗？是的，我住在那儿。你家里都有谁？我家里有我、我两个弟弟，
two of my best friends live with me. What about you? I went to drama school with. We have the most timid version of my best friends lived with me. Wait a minute. I went to drama school with. We have the most timid version of what a frat house would be. We're all obsessed with golf. We get early nights and we're on the tee early in the morning. So... Can I move in?
我最好的朋友中的两个跟我一起住。你呢？我和我一起上戏剧学校的。我们过着最温和版本的兄弟会生活。我们所有人都对高尔夫着迷。我们很早就睡觉，一大早在发球台上集合。所以……我可以搬进去吗？
I know this is our dream come true. I actually have spare space, please. I'm loving what somebody has a deep allergy to golf, and it's not great for my game. I'm just picturing Jason living with all of you 20 somethings and there's a 54 year old living with 27. You have a room. You have a really grumpy hungry 54 year old.
我知道这是我们的梦想成真。我其实有空房间，求你了。我很喜欢那种对高尔夫严重过敏的人，这可对我的球技没啥帮助。我简直无法想象杰森和你们这群二十多岁的小伙子住在一起，一个54岁的人和27岁的人住在一起。你有一个房间。你有一个脾气暴躁、肚子饿得咕咕叫的54岁老头。
Oh, I know my salads won't get eaten in the fridge. That's true. Those foods will still be safe. So hang on, it's your two brothers and two friends that eaten in the fridge. That's true. Those things will still be safe. So hang on, it's your two brothers and two friends that are in the house with you. Yeah, so it's me, Sam, Harry, and then Harrison and Twain. And we're all in there together. It's a pretty harmonious experience.
哦，我知道我的沙拉在冰箱里不会被吃掉。那倒是真的。那些食物还是很安全的。等等，所以是你的两个弟弟和两个朋友跟你住在房子里。是的，所以有我、萨姆、哈利，还有哈里森和特温。我们都住在一起。这是一次相当和谐的经历。
Everyone kind of does their bit. We look after the house, someone cooks. My brother, Sam, actually, thankfully, is a professional chef, which is a touch, like you come home and he's practicing and doing what he does best and you get gourmet food every night. Does he cook?
每个人都做自己分内的事。我们照看房子，有人做饭。我弟弟萨姆，谢天谢地，实际上是一名专业厨师，这真是一大幸事，你回到家时他正在练习，做他最擅长的事，你每天晚上都能吃到美食。他做饭吗？
Every night? Every night, yeah, it's glorious. So he's rent-free then, right? Oh, absolutely, absolutely. He rent-free. And how much you want to bet there's a big TV in the house? There's a glorious TV. I just actually put in a little drop-down screen
每天晚上？每天晚上，是的，太棒了。所以他不用交房租了，对吧？哦，绝对的，绝对的。他免房租。你敢打赌房子里一定有个大电视吗？有个超棒的电视。我刚刚在里面装了一个小型的下拉式屏幕
for movies and we play poker, put the golf on and sit down. It's a glorious TV. I just actually put in a little drop-down screen for movies and we play poker put the golf on and sit down It's it's a vibe. Well, that's what I was doing. I'm moving out of You're ever in London and you want to play some poker and watch the golf on a Sunday night This master's weekend past weekend one of the best weekends of my life. Yeah, Tom We keep it going be 27 when you 27. Just knock it out of the park. Good for you. So you're the oldest of four boys, Tom, right? Yes.
用来放电影，我们玩扑克，播放高尔夫比赛然后坐下来看。这感觉太棒了。这就是我一直在做的。我要搬出……如果你去伦敦，想在周日晚上打打扑克、看高尔夫比赛，刚刚过去的美国大师赛（Masters）周末是我一生中最美好的周末之一。是的，汤姆，我们继续保持，27岁就要大展身手。真为你高兴。所以你是四个男孩里最大的，汤姆，对吧？是的。
And your parents were both artists. Tell me about like growing up and like with your, with your mom. Like what did your mom and dad do? So my mom's a, she was a photographer. And sort of like a lifestyle photographer. Like she'd take families out to the park and take pictures of them and do that sort of stuff
你父母都是艺术家。跟我聊聊你的成长经历，还有你妈妈。你爸爸妈妈是做什么的？我妈妈是一名摄影师。有点像生活方式摄影师。比如她会带家庭去公园，给他们拍照，做诸如此类的事。
My dad's a stand-up and he has been since he was What? That's the one. I think Does he still do it? Oh, yeah, yeah, he's still gigging all the time and really He's a pleasure like he's hilarious. I can't bring anyone over to my house without him absolutely just ripping them a new one. And, you know, I have to like prepare my friends just so you know my dad's a standout.
我爸爸是个单口喜剧演员，他从很小就开始了。什么？就是那个。我想他还在演吗？哦，是的，是的，他一直在演出，真的很棒。他是个开心果，他太搞笑了。我没法带任何人来我家，除非他把对方贬得体无完肤。而且，你知道的，我必须提前警告我的朋友们，顺便说一句，我爸爸是个单口喜剧演员。
Especially when I was young, I didn't understand what it was. I was like, apparently he fucking goes out and tells jokes at night or something. I don't know what it is that he does. He's gonna take the piss. And you guys basically provide him material, right? So, does all the family stuff work into his sets? Yeah, there's a few things.
特别是当我小的时候，我不懂那是怎么回事。我想，显然他每晚都出去讲笑话什么的。我不知道他在搞什么鬼。他肯定会拿人开涮。你们基本上是在为他提供素材，对吧？所以，家庭里的那些事都会变成他的演出素材吗？是的，有那么一些。
I've been to see him a, like, a hand for the times when he'll allow us to go and see him. And I don't know if he, like, plays up to it that we're in the audience or if he, you know, if that's what he's like all the time, but it's pretty ruthless. But that's my poor mom. My mom has got the thickest skin of anyone I've ever met
我去听过他几次演出，只要他允许我们去看的话。我不知道他是因为我们在台下而故意表现得夸张，还是他平时就是这个样子，但他的台风相当无情。不过我可怜的妈妈。我妈妈拥有我见过的所有人中最厚脸皮的
in my life because the shit that he comes out with, I mean, he did a charity gig for my school, one else. So all my mum's best friends are there, all my kids, all of my school friends are there, all the school teachers are there, and the shit that he was coming out about my mum. It's a terrible idea. But the thing is, she finds it hilarious.
这辈子因为他爆出来的那些料，我的意思是，他为我的学校做过一次慈善演出，有一次。所以妈妈所有的好朋友都在场，我所有的孩子们，我所有的学校朋友都在场，所有的学校老师也都在场，而他爆出的关于我妈妈的那些料。真是个糟糕的主意。但关键是，她觉得太搞笑了。
She's sitting there laughing, she gets the last laugh, and she's an amazing lady. I'm so sorry. Jason does some sort of thing. He's got one joke. It's great. Well, which one? God, please.
她坐在那里笑，笑到最后，她是个了不起的女士。我很抱歉。杰森在搞什么鬼。他有一个笑话。很棒。好吧，哪个？天哪，求你了。
Please don't. No, I want to do a pro-todd. God, it's the worst. I don't know how to tell it, but it's funny. Just trust me, Tom, all right? So, and all your brother, everybody's in the biz. Well, it's so awesome. I mean, except for the chef.
求你了，别这样。不，我想来一个。天哪，太糟糕了。我不知道该怎么讲，但它很好笑。相信我，汤姆，好吗？所以，还有你弟弟，每个人都在这个行业。太棒了。我的意思是，除了那个厨师。
Except for the chef. He's a caterer, onset caterer. On set caterer, we could get him in there, trap him in the cage that they keep those working. But everybody works as actors, no? Paddy's an actor, the younger one's an actor, but he's too young to really say he's an actor. He's like still at school, still enjoying himself.
除了厨师。他是餐饮人员，片场餐饮人员。片场餐饮人员，我们可以把他弄进去，关在关那些工作人员的笼子里。但每个人都在当演员，对吧？帕迪是个演员，小一点的那个也是个演员，但他太小了，还不能真正算是个演员。他还在上学，还在享受生活。
He is lucky enough to be working in the summer and enjoys it. I don't think it's what he feels 100% that he wants to do. But he loves it, and he's really good at it. He's super, super talented, and he's very natural. My younger brother, Harry, who's here with me in New York right now, he's a young aspiring filmmaker. He has his first short premiering tomorrow at Tribeca,
他很幸运能在夏天打工并且乐在其中。我不认为这是他百分之百想做的事。但他很喜欢，而且他真的很擅长。他超级超级有天赋，非常自然。我弟弟哈利，现在跟我一起在纽约，是一个有抱负的年轻电影人。他的第一部短片明天将在翠贝卡电影节（Tribeca）首映，
which is super exciting. Oh, that's great. Oh, that's great. That's great. Yeah, that's really cool. We'll be right back. Smartlet's get support from Helix. You know, I'm in New York doing a show, as you well know,
这超级令人兴奋。哦，那太棒了。哦，那太棒了。太棒了。是的，这真的很酷。我们马上回来。SmartLess受到Helix的支持。你知道的，我在纽约演出，正如你们所知，
but when I get home, I'm going to have my Helix mattress and I can't wait. I sleep so great. I'm in New York doing a show, as you well know, but when I get home, I'm gonna have my Helix mattress and I can't wait. I sleep so great, I'm a Helix mattress. To remind you, I got the Helix Dusk Lux mattress, but hey, we're all different. There's plenty to choose from. The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Lux Collection,
但当我回到家时，我将拥有我的Helix床垫，我已经迫不及待了。我睡得太香了，我用的是Helix床垫。提醒一下，我买的是Helix Dusk Lux床垫，但是嘿，我们各不相同。有很多选择可供挑选。Helix系列提供20款独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Lux系列，
the newly released Helix Elite Collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. Let's talk about the new high-end Helix Elite collection. It includes six different mattress models, each tailored for specific sleep positions and firmness preferences. Nervous about buying a mattress online, don't be. The Helix Sleep Quiz takes into account your individual sleep preferences to match you and your partner with the perfect mattress for you.
新发布的Helix Elite系列，专为身材高大的人设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童设计的床垫。我们来聊聊全新高端的Helix Elite系列。它包括六种不同的床垫模型，每种都针对特定的睡眠姿势和硬度偏好进行了定制。担心在线购买床垫吗？别担心。Helix睡眠测试会将你个人的睡眠偏好考虑在内，为你和你的伴侣匹配最完美的床垫。
And your personalized mattresses ship straight to your door free of charge plus Helix mattress is all come with a 10 or 15 year warranty depending on the model. Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixleap.com slash smartless. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. With helix, better sleep starts now. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know when I was a lot younger,
而且你个性化的床垫会免费直接运送到你家门口，此外Helix床垫根据型号不同，均提供10年或15年保修。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单8折优惠以及两个免费枕头。访问helixsleep.com/smartless。这是他们有史以来最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ SmartLess由BetterHelp赞助。你知道的，当我年轻得多的时候，
as most younger people feel, you're a little lost about like, how do you do this, where do you go, if I want this for a career, if I want that for a relationship, if I want this with my friend, or if I don't want, you know, whatever your relationships are to all of the things in your life, you can feel uncertain about it, right?
正如大多数年轻人所感受到的那样，你会感到有点迷茫，比如：怎么做这个，去哪里，如果我想把这个作为事业，如果我想建立那样的关系，如果我想和朋友这样，或者如果我不想，你知道的，无论你对生活中所有事情的关系是什么，你都会对此感到不确定，对吧？
I think we've all kind of felt that. And sometimes in life we're faced with tough choices and the path forward isn't always clear. I'm on Broadway right now, and of course, you know, even though I'm exhausted and I'm working all the time I can always find a half hour or an hour to speak to somebody if things start feeling overwhelming right so whether you're dealing with decisions around career relationships or anything else therapy helps you stay connected to what you really want while you navigate life so you can move forward with confidence and excitement trusting yourself to make decisions that align with your
我想我们都有过这种感觉。有时在生活中我们会面临艰难的选择，前方的道路并不总是清晰的。我现在正在百老汇演出，当然，你知道，尽管我精疲力竭，一直在工作，但我总能抽出半小时或一小时和别人聊聊，如果事情开始让人感到难以承受的话，对吧？所以，无论你是在处理关于职业、关系还是其他任何事情的决定，心理治疗都能帮助你保持与内心真正渴望的事物的联系，同时在人生旅途中前行，让你满怀自信和兴奋地继续前进，相信自己能够做出符合你
values is like anything. The more you practice it, the easier it gets. It's actually exactly what my therapist says. I know every single time I talk to my therapist, I always, always feel better afterwards. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help a try. It's entirely online,
价值观的决定，这就像任何事情一样。你练习得越多，它就变得越容易。这其实正是我的心理治疗师说过的话。我知道每次我和心理治疗师谈话时，事后我总是、总是会感觉好一些。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线，
designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with the licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Let therapy be your map with better help. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month.
旨在提供便捷、灵活的服务，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简单的问卷，就能与有执照的治疗师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。让BetterHelp成为你的生活指南针。今天就访问betterhelp.com/smartless，首月即可享受9折优惠。
That's betterhelp.htlp.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from CarMax. Sometimes the idea of selling your car can seem like a mystery movie, right? But with CarMax instant online offers, it can feel more like a rom-com, stay with me people. Now picture this, a person meets a sports car and falls in love. Then that person meets a person and they fall in love and start a family. Uh-oh, now that sports car has falls in love. Then that person meets a person, and they fall in love and start a family. Uh-oh, now that sports car has got to go. But don't worry, CarMax saves the day
网址是betterhelp.com/smartless。SmartLess获得CarMax的支持。有时候，卖车的想法看起来像是一部悬疑电影，对吧？但有了CarMax即时在线报价，它感觉更像是一部浪漫喜剧，大家听我说。现在想象一下，一个人遇到了一辆跑车并坠入爱河。然后那个人遇到了一个人，他们坠入爱河并组建了家庭。哦哦，现在那辆跑车不得不出手了。但别担心，CarMax通过CarMax.com上的即时报价拯救了局面。
with an instant offer at CarMax.com. Ta-da! Now our happy couple has a real offer from CarMax and can start searching for the perfect family car for that baby, baby, and live happily ever after. That's Car Selling Reimagined at CarMax. All right, back to the show. Does your dad, like,
铛铛！现在我们幸福的情侣从CarMax获得了真实的报价，并可以开始为那个宝贝、宝贝寻找完美的家庭用车，从此过上幸福快乐的生活。这就是CarMax重塑的汽车销售方式。好了，回到节目中。你爸爸，他，
does he hang out with other comics where there are other comics around the house growing up? Did you spend time with, are those his mates? Well, remember, like, his kids, like, going to barbecues and stuff and being aware of the comic scene and like knowing them as dad's work friends and just thinking like, wow, dad has like the strangest group of friends.
他会和其他喜剧演员一起闲逛吗？你从小到大身边是不是有很多其他喜剧演员？你会花时间跟他们在一起吗，那些是他球友吗？好吧，记住，就像他的孩子们去参加烧烤派对什么的，对喜剧圈有所了解，把他们当作爸爸的工作朋友，并且觉得，哇，爸爸有一群最奇怪的朋友。
Like they are really sad people, man. Like I thought he was supposed to fucking make people laugh. And my dad is like, my dad is a very happy, go lucky, you know, positive guy. I feel like my dad's a giver. He comes into a room and he gives a great energy and fuck, some of his friends come in and you're like, wow, what happened to that guy?
就像他们真的是一群沉闷的人，老兄。我觉得他应该去逗笑别人才对。我爸爸是一个非常随和、乐观、积极的人。我觉得我爸爸是个乐于奉献的人。他走进一个房间，会带来极佳的能量，该死的，他的一些朋友走进来时，你会想，哇，那家伙怎么了？
You know, and then you see him on TV and you're like, he's hilarious. I think he's fantastic. It's a tricky one. Is his brand of humor, my mother's British. And so I got kind of like a dry appreciation for dry humor. Is he dry like that? Or is your humor dry like that? He's British. And so I got kind of like a dry appreciation for dry humor. Is he dry like that?
你知道的，然后你在电视上看到他，你会觉得，他太搞笑了。我觉得他太棒了。这是一个棘手的问题。他的幽默风格是怎样的，我妈妈是英国人。所以我对黑色幽默有一种干巴巴的欣赏。他也是那种冷幽默吗？或者说你的幽默也是那种干巴巴的风格？他很幽默。我想我也挺冷幽默的。他让素材自己说话。他不是那种表演型的喜剧演员。他真的很信任自己的素材，依靠笑话本身，而且他知道这很好笑。所以他不会画蛇添足。
Or is your humor dry like that? He's dry. I'd say I'm pretty dry too. He lets the material do the talking. Like he's not a performative comedian. Like he really trusts his material and he belies on the joke and he knows it's funny. So he doesn't add to it.
一切都非常单一。但我喜欢那种风格。这意味着素材必须更好。你对喜剧题材感兴趣吗？你想不想开始疯狂拍一堆喜剧，做那种类型的事情？我一直、一直、一直都想演喜剧。不久前我在巴西，我做了一个节目，我想那是我的个人秀的一部分，那是我的个人秀的一部分。台下大约有7,000名观众。
Everything is very kind of one note. But I like that sort of thing. It means the material has to be better. Are you drawn towards comedy stuff? Do you want to start banging out a bunch of comedies and do that kind of thing? I've always, always, always wanted to do a comedy. It wasn't too long ago I was doing, I was in Brazil and I did this show for, I think it was part of my two, it was part of my one. It was like 7,000 people in the audience.
我在舞台上待了一个小时，有一个主持人问我各种问题。那是我一生中最棒的体验，因为我感觉自己像个摇滚巨星。我说的每句话，每个人都在他妈的笑。所以我给我爸打电话说，爸爸，爸爸。我刚在舞台上讲了一个小时，效果炸裂了。
And I was on stage for an hour with a compaer who was like asking me questions and stuff. And it was the greatest experience of my life because I felt like a rock star. Like everything I said, everyone was fucking laugh. So I called my dad and was like, dad, dad. I just did like an hour on stage and like I fucking ripped the shit out of it.
我们做这个吧。帮我写点喜剧。结果他直接挂了电话。他说，这种事可不是经常发生的。真的吗？不过是的，现在我还没有胆量走上舞台去做他做的事。但我总有一天很想演一部喜剧。
Like let's do this. Like help me write some comedy. And he just hung out. He was like, it has never happened in some time. Really? But yeah, now I'm not bold enough to step on stage and do what he does. But I'd love to do a comedy one day.
有哪些演员能让你发笑？你像我一样是个威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）的粉丝和那些家伙的粉丝吗？还是你更喜欢那些通过塑造角色而不是表现得夸张来搞笑的演员的喜剧？或者我猜威尔就是这样的。威尔塑造的角色都很有深度，就像他演过很多威尔的电影。我喜欢他的角色。我喜欢威尔的作品。我喜欢他的即兴表演能力。你演的东西毫无疑问是我的最爱。好吧，但我并不像阿内特、法瑞尔或那些真正懂得如何逗笑别人的人那样搞笑。我是那种你去找来扮演，嗯，那个不笑的人。是的，但这也很好笑，我喜欢那样。
Who are some of the actors that make you laugh that are like, are you like a welfare fan like me and those folks or do you like comedy that comes a little bit more from actors that are doing a character as opposed to being being broad or I guess Will does. Will does really deep characters that are like he's a lot of will stuff. I love his his ability Will does really deep characters that are like he, those characters. I love Will's stuff. I love his, his ability to improv. The stuff that you do is my favorite without a shadow of a doubt. Well, but I'm not being funny, funny like our net or a feral or folks that really know how to get people. I'm the guy you turn to, to sort of like, the guy who's not laughing. Yeah, but that's funny though, I like that.
那是冷幽默吗？差不多，对吧？是的，我也很喜欢。我他妈太喜欢你在《恶老板》（Horrible bosses）里说的那句台词了，当你开着普锐斯（Prius）或者别的什么车的时候，是那部电影吗？哦，对，没错。
Is that dry humor? It's similar. They're right, right? Yeah, I love it too. I fucking love that line you do and you said, when you're driving in a Prius or something, is it in horrible bosses? Oh, all right, yeah.
他说，你在开普锐斯赛车？我赢不了多少。我喜欢那样。这就是你在做的事。这就是你在做的事。是的，我觉得很酷的一件事是，你是一个直男，却去上了芭蕾舞课。我觉得，（并不是说直男不能学，或是只有同性恋才学之类的话），但这就好像，你知道我的意思吗？
He's like, you were tag racing in a Prius? I don't win a lot. I like that. That's what you're doing. That's what you're doing. Yeah, one of the things I think is super cool is that you're a straight guy who took ballet lessons. I think that's, you know, not that straight guys can or just gay guys do or whatever, but it's like, you know what I mean?
看到你挑战这个让人耳目一新。那是九岁的时候吗？是那样吗？是的，我当时正在为西区的一部名为《跳出我天地》（Billy Elliott）的演出进行训练。是的。我当时去了一所非常传统的橄榄球学校。我小时候是个挺不错的橄榄球队员，然后大家都长高了，而我依然是那个最矮的孩子，直到今天也是。我根本无法参加12岁以下的联赛。我太小了。所以这吃了不少苦头。我记得当时在学校被霸凌，试图说服别人……
It's refreshing to see you tackle that. And was nine years old? Was that what it was? Yeah, I was I was I was training for this show on the West End at the time, called Billy Elliott. Yeah. And I went to like a very traditional rugby school. I was pretty good rugby player as a kid and then everyone just grew and I stayed the smallest kid even today. I couldn't compete in the under 12 league. I'd be too. So it's taken some injuries. And I just, I remember like getting bullied at school and trying to convince people like,
很高兴看到你应对那个挑战。当时是九岁对吧？是那样吗？是的，我当时正在为西区的一个名叫《跳出我天地》的演出进行训练。是的。我去了一所非常传统的主打橄榄球的学校。我小时候是个挺不错的橄榄球运动员，然后大家都长高了，而我依然是那个最小的孩子，直到今天也是。我都无法参加12岁以下级别的联赛，我太小了。所以这带来了一些伤病。我只记得在学校里被霸凌，然后试图去说服别人……
guys, there's me and 30 girls in tights on a daily basis and telling you like rugby is not where this is at. Like, you join me. But I could never convince anyone. But I loved ballet. For me as an actor, like, especially doing things like Spider-Man, that are so physical.
伙计们，我每天要和30个穿紧身衣的女孩在一起，我跟你说，练橄榄球可不是这样的。就像你加入我一样。但我从来没说服过任何人。但我热爱芭蕾。对我而言，作为一名演员，特别是拍像《蜘蛛侠》这种动作戏如此之多的电影。
It comes in handy. It's been such a great resource to rely on. And that's that I've lost every ounce of flexibility. But you're obviously a big, and you mentioned that you played rugby a bit, and that you like sports, you like golf. I saw you waving the checkered flag in Monaco last week. Yes, that was crazy.
这很有用。这真是一个可以信赖的绝佳资源。那就是我失去了每一丝柔韧性。但你显然是一个超级……你提到过你以前踢过一点橄榄球，你喜欢运动，你喜欢高尔夫。我上周看到你在摩纳哥挥舞方格旗了。是的，那太疯狂了。
It's great going to those races, isn't it? Dude, like one of the best weekends I've ever had. I took all my brothers, I took some friends, and until you've been there and like seen it for real, you're hearing it. And hearing it? And you feel it, right, when they, I mean, it's insane. And it like, you can feel your ribcage.
去观看那些比赛感觉太棒了，对吧？老兄，那绝对是我经历过的最棒的周末之一。我带上了我所有的兄弟，带上了一些朋友，直到你亲自去到现场，亲眼目睹，亲耳听到。听到那种声音？那种震撼感，当它们……我的意思是，这太疯狂了。你会感觉你的胸腔都在震动。
Especially there too, all those engine it's insane. And it, like, you can feel your rib cage. Especially there, too. All those engine noises going through all those buildings, through those corridors. Right, it's just the actual... And also, like, at the end of the day, like, qualifies done, they open the track. You can walk from restaurant to restaurant, via the track, and, like, see the tire marks across the floor.
尤其是现场，所有的发动机……这太疯狂了。而且，那种感觉，你的胸腔都在共鸣。尤其是那个地方。所有的发动机轰鸣声穿过所有的建筑，穿过那些走廊。没错，那种真实的……而且，说到底，排位赛结束时，他们会开放赛道。你可以通过赛道从一家餐厅走到另一家餐厅，还能看到地面上的轮胎印。
It's, it's, unlike, I love sport, I'm obsessed. It's, like, it's, you know, I'll watch anything that's on telly. Yeah, do you watch, are you watch, are you a big football fan? I'm like a soccer fan. Yeah. Yeah, I'm a Tottenham fan, regrettably. Are you? Yeah, it's tough, man.
这……这简直，我热爱运动，我简直到了痴迷的地步。这就像是，你知道的，电视上播什么我都看。对，你看……你是那种超级狂热的足球迷吗？我算是个英式足球迷。对。对，我其实是个托特纳姆热刺队的球迷，虽然挺让人遗憾的。是吗？对，日子不好过啊，老兄。
Man, this is a tough spell you guys are going through. I mean, you've got that new manager, but still it's a tough time to be. We didn't care for Tottenham, Willie. You sure did, yeah. It's all about Garas Bale. Yeah, we played golf with Garas Bale. We played the Bunch. He's a good golfer, I had He sure did, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, we play golf with Garrett the bunch.
老兄，你们现在经历的这段时期确实够难的。我的意思是，你们换了新教练，但现在支持他们依然是个艰难的时期。我们可不在乎热刺，威利。你明明在乎，没错。关键在于加雷斯·贝尔。对，我们和加雷斯·贝尔一起打过高尔夫。我们打过一局。他是个好高尔夫球手，我……他确实在乎，没错。对。对，我们和加雷斯打过一场。
Yeah, he's a good golfer. I have really good. Yeah, he would love him. Yeah, he's got a really pretty swing, doesn't he? Yeah, yeah. Willie, you into your socket? You sported too? Yeah, yeah, I'm a Liverpool supporter.
对，他是个很棒的高尔夫球手。我真的很厉害。对，他会很喜欢他的。对，他的挥杆动作非常漂亮，对吧？对，对。威利，你也喜欢足球吗？你也支持哪支球队吗？对，对，我是利物浦的球迷。
We're a Liverpool supporter. Okay. Yeah, I'm a massive, massive supporter I watched. I was at World Cup. I mean, I'm a massive fan. Oh, wow. How did you come to Liverpool? My partner, my writing partner, not just to clarify. Yeah, I know you're straight.
我们是利物浦的球迷。好吧。对，我是个超级、超级狂热的球迷，我看比赛。我去过世界杯。我的意思是，我是一个超级球迷。哦，哇。你是怎么成为利物浦球迷的？我的搭档，我的写作搭档，为了澄清一下，不是那种伴侣。对，我知道你是直男。
It's take a minute. I don't know. I'm just, I would do ballet too, by the way. I have no problem. Come on, let's do it. I would, I would. Mark Chappell, the great chap, he whom these guys know is.
等一下。我不知道。我只是……顺便说一句，我也会跳芭蕾。我一点问题都没有。来吧，我们一起跳。我会的，我会的。马克·查佩尔，那个了不起的家伙，这几位伙计都知道他。
Once in a lifetime. He lives in London. He lives in London, but he's a big Liverpool sport and he got me in deliver pool. Okay. And I was saying the other day, like I wasn't really as aware of it. I mean, I love any sports. Jason's the same. I'll watch anything. So...
千载难逢。他住在伦敦。他住在伦敦，但他是个超级利物浦球迷，他把我带入了利物浦的阵营。好吧。我前几天还在说，我以前其实没那么关注。我的意思是，我热爱所有运动。杰森也一样。什么我都看。所以……
And then got into soccer, you know, football like 12 years ago. And once I got into it and got deeper into it, it just, yeah, I'm a massive hockey fan growing up in Canada. And then football has now surpassed hockey, I think. I just, I can't get enough of it, man. Do you guys know all the chance, you know, I think it's so cool that there's, I wish we had chance in baseball, you know.
然后大约12年前开始接触足球。一旦我接触了它，并且深入了解之后，就一发不可收拾了，对，我在加拿大长大，是个狂热的曲棍球迷。然后足球现在已经超越了曲棍球，我想是的。我简直对它爱不释手，老兄。你们知道所有的球迷助威歌吗，我觉得有助威歌这事太酷了，我真希望棒球比赛里也有助威歌，你知道的。
Some of the chance, like, I remember going to see a basketball game in New York and people like, dude, you're not going to believe the atmosphere. Like, it's going to blow your socks off. And then you get there and it's like, let's get louder. And I'm not just trying to shut up. Like, let's come up with something better than this. Wait, Jay, they have that organ.
有些助威歌，就像，我记得我去纽约看一场篮球比赛，人们说，老兄，你绝对不敢相信现场的气氛。简直会让你大吃一惊。然后你到了那儿，发现情况就像是：让我们声音大点！我心里只想让他们闭嘴。咱们能想出点比这更好的东西吗？等等，杰伊，他们有那种管风琴。
Da, da, da, da, da, da. Oh, I know. That's it. It's a one word chant. Yeah. The chant, the chant in football in Europe and in England, in the Premier League are not only they so good, some of them are so clever and hilarious.
哒，哒，哒，哒，哒，哒。哦，我知道。就是那个。那是一个词的助威。对。欧洲、英国以及英超联赛中的足球助威，不仅非常精彩，而且其中有些甚至极其聪明、搞笑。
And they just sound haunting as it goes through the quarrel. And you go to some of these places, you go to Versailles, you go to Marseilles, you go to Germany, Dortmund, and see these teams, like the way they rally together, and how song just like explodes out of people somehow in unison. I don't understand how it happened. That's a true home field advantage. The first, the first professional football match I went to is in Madrid for Atlético Madrid
当它们在看台回荡时，听起来甚至有点神秘莫测。当你去到其中一些地方，你去到凡尔赛，你去到马赛，你去到德国的多特蒙德，看着这些球队，看着他们团结一致的方式，听着歌声不知怎么地就从人们口中异口同声地爆发出来。我真不明白那是怎么做到的。这才是真正的本土作战优势。我去的的第一场职业足球比赛是在马德里，看马德里竞技队的比赛
at their old stadium. And I was not, and it was Sunday night game. I remember it like sort of eight o'clock. And I was not prepared for the chance and the feeling in the crowd. Nobody sat the entire match. Everybody was standing and it was electric. Just even if you were in a fan of the sport as a human being, it was an experience. Now, are you still watching rugby? I like rugby. I mean, I love rugby. I love the sport. I think it's amazing. I don't love rugby culture. Right. Oh, yeah.
在他们的新球场。我当时……那是一场周日晚上的比赛。我记得大约是八点左右。我完全没有准备好面对看台上的助威声和那种热烈的气氛。整场比赛没有人坐着。所有人都站着，气氛简直燃爆了。哪怕你不是这项运动的球迷，作为一个普通人，这也是一次难忘的体验。话说回来，你现在还看橄榄球吗？我喜欢橄榄球。我的意思是，我热爱橄榄球。我热爱这项运动。我认为它太棒了。但我不太喜欢橄榄球文化。没错。哦，是的。
Rugby culture is so much about like, how much can you drink? Let's all get as drunk as possible. And I don't drink. So I'm a little bit like out of that world. Right, right. Do you ever see Australian rules? Aussie rules is crazy. Yeah. It's sort of a hybrid of soccer. It's good. Have you ever been to one of those matches down there? It's amazing. I haven't known. It's someone like, have you ever seen Gaelic football?
橄榄球文化太关注于：你能喝多少酒？让我们一起喝得烂醉如泥吧。而我不喝酒。所以我跟那个世界有点格格不入。对，对。你见过澳式橄榄球吗？澳式橄榄球太疯狂了。对。它有点像是足球的混合体。挺不错的。你去现场看过那种比赛吗？太棒了。我没去过。有人……你见过盖尔式足球吗？
Oh, yeah. Gaelic football is, I guess, like, the Irish equivalent to Aussie rules. Oh, yeah. But another sport you should check out, I think it's called herlling. Yeah, herlling. And they have, like, a hockey stick. But the end of the hockey stick is slightly wider. Right.
哦，对。盖尔式足球，我猜，就像是爱尔兰版的澳式橄榄球。哦，对。但还有一项运动你应该了解一下，我想它叫爱尔兰式曲棍球。对，爱尔兰式曲棍球。他们拿着一根类似曲棍球杆的东西。但曲棍球杆的底部要稍微宽一点。没错。
They have, I think, as a wooden ball. And they basically, like, flick it up. They have, I think it's a wooden ball. And they basically like flick it up. And they catch it on it and they, they have bloody, they're bruised. It sounds like you can get hurt. It's sort of like, it's polo without the horses. Right?
他们有一个，我记得是个木球。然后他们基本上就是……把球挑起来。他们有一个，我认为是木球。然后他们基本上就像这样把球挑起来。用球杆接住它，他们常常弄得浑身是血、青一块紫一块的。听起来很容易受伤。这有点像是……没有马球马的马球。对吧？
That's exactly what it is. Sounds like quidditch. Quidditch. Oh, she's so edgy. Hey guys, hey guys, what's up? Quick, quick, quick, quick shout out from the nerd department. Hey guys, that reminds me a lot of Quintet, Shay. And according to the rules, Hey, Tom, how did with all of this,
完全就是这样。听起来像魁地奇。魁地奇。哦，你太时髦了。嘿，伙计们，嘿，伙计们，怎么啦？来自书呆子部门的快速、快速、快速、快速致意。嘿，伙计们，这让我想起了昆特特，谢伊。根据规则，嘿，汤姆，这一切是怎么……
what was your first, how did you start? What was your first thing as an actor? Like, what your first thing where you're like, I got it, I want to be an actor, I want to do this. I want to be in a play. I want it like, what was your first thing as an actor? Like, your first thing where you're like, I got it, I want to be an actor, I want to do this, I want to be in a play, I want it, like, what was it? Apparently I used to love this one Janet Jackson song when I was a kid. Which one?
你的第一次经历是什么？你是怎么开始的？你作为演员的第一个作品是什么？比如，你是哪一刻突然觉得：我懂了，我想成为一名演员，我想做这个。我想参演一出戏剧。我想要……比如，你作为演员的第一个作品是什么？比如，你是在哪个瞬间突然觉得：我懂了，我想成为一名演员，我想做这个，我想演话剧，我想要……比如，到底是什么？好像我小时候特别喜欢珍妮·杰克逊的一首歌。哪一首歌？
I live for her. Oh boy. I don't know what it is, but apparently my mom posted it for my birthday, a video of me as a kid dancing to it, and apparently Janet Jackson actually reposted it. Like, was it like rhythm nation or something like that? I don't know, I could find it. But anyway, my mom just...
我为她而狂热。哦，天哪。我不知道为什么，但显然我妈妈为我的生日发过一个视频，视频里我还是个小男孩，随着这首歌跳舞，而且据说珍妮·杰克逊真的转发了这个视频。等等，是像《Rhythm Nation》那类歌曲吗？我不知道，我可能还能找到。总之，我妈只是……
I was one of her backup dancers. I was one of them. Yes, I was one of them. I was on a little grace and Sean and I had it. You were the picture of the hands, that wasn't you? No, Sean and I had a dance off on an episode of Will and Grace once. With Janet Jackson.
我是她的伴舞之一。我是其中之一。是的，我就是其中之一。我在《威尔和格蕾丝》里和肖恩有一场对舞。和珍妮·杰克逊一起。
With Janet Jackson. Jason came to taping. Yeah, you got to Google that, Tom. It's life-changing. I'm going to look that up. Yeah, it's pretty good. But I'm... Okay, so wait, so you were in a Janet.
和珍妮·杰克逊一起。杰森去现场看了录制。对，你得去谷歌一下，汤姆。这简直能改变人生。我要去查一下。对，挺精彩的。不过我……好吧，等等，所以你曾在一支珍妮的……
I would do these hip-hop glasses on a Saturday, and I got spotted by this headmaster of this school to audition for Billie Elyette. They started training me and doing ballet, and all that sort of stuff. I ended up auditioning for this show, because I thought it would be fun. I enjoyed the process of auditioning.
我周六去上这种嘻哈舞蹈班，然后被这所学校的校长发掘，去试镜《跳出我天地》。他们开始对我进行训练，教我跳芭蕾以及诸如此类的事情。我最后去为这个剧试镜，因为我觉得这会挺好玩的。我很享受试镜的过程。
I got the gig. I got an agent through the gig. My parents were like, well, I mean, there's no harm in having an agent. They sent me one screen test, self-tape for a film. I did it, I was like 12, and I got the part, and it was this film called The Impossible
我拿到了这份工作。我通过这个工作签了经纪人。我父母当时想，好吧，反正找个经纪人也没什么坏处。他们给我发了一次银幕测试，是一部电影的自录试镜。我照做了，当时我大概12岁，然后我得到了这个角色，那是部叫《海啸奇迹》的电影。
when you were in the box, because about the tsunami. It's another film called the impossible. Yeah, the impossible. Because about the tsunami. It's another one of your questions, Sean. I'm sure. It's definitely. And then I just... Good for you, Tom. You get the picture now.
当你身处那个箱子里的时候，因为是关于海啸的。那是另一部电影叫《海啸奇迹》。这是你的另一个问题，肖恩。我确信。绝对是的。然后我只是……真为你高兴，汤姆。你现在明白了吧。
You're getting it. Welcome to our life. And then I just never stopped doing it. I just kind of, I guess I reached that age where I was maybe 16, 17. I was like, I can either keep my head down and like stick with school and try and figure out what I would do if I'm going to get millions and crushing ass, right? It's a tough choice. Tom, it sounds like from a young age you had very naturally what Jason likes to call sexy and difference. We'll be right back after these things.
你慢慢懂了。欢迎来到我们的生活。然后我就再也没有停下过。我只是觉得……我猜我到了那个年龄，大概16、17岁吧。我当时想：我可以继续埋头苦读，坚持上学，然后去琢磨如果我要赚几百万并大获成功的话该做些什么，对吧？这真是一个艰难的选择。汤姆，听起来你从小就自然而然地具备了杰森喜欢称之为“性感与冷漠”的特质。我们稍作休息，广告之后马上回来。
Um, because you guys don't care. I love that he's like, I just didn't care. And I just thought, yeah, I got this part. I know what I got this movie in and look what happens. Meanwhile, Sean is begging. He's that casting director. His doors are just flocks. Like begging.
嗯，因为你们根本不在乎。我太喜欢他那种“我根本不在乎”的态度了。我当时就想，是的，我拿到这个角色了。我早就知道我能拿下这部电影，看看结果怎么样。与此同时，肖恩却在苦苦哀求。他去找那个选秀导演。人家的门都直接关上了。就像在乞求一样。
I got a new headshot. I don't know if you've seen it. Make a cross. He did. He did. He did. He did. He did.
我拍了一张新的演员头条照。我不知道你们有没有看过。做个鬼脸。他确实拍了。他真的拍了。他确实拍了。他拍了。
He did. He did. He did. He did. He did. He did. in a fucking Hawaiian punch commercial, you know, I mean, just, I'm pleased. My payment with free product. Tom, when did you start perfecting your American accent? Because it's just, it's, it's, it's, it's seamless. It's very, it's very, it's very, it's very, it's very, it's,
他拍了。他拍了。他拍了。他拍了。他拍了。他拍了。在一支该死的夏威夷果汁广告里，你知道的，我的意思是，真高兴。我的报酬是免费产品。汤姆，你是从什么时候开始练习并完善你的美国口音的？因为听起来简直……简直天衣无缝。太……太……太流利了。
and is it hard, I've asked this before, is American accent hard to do? I think as a Brit, we're so, uh, like surrounded by American culture. We watch your shows, we watch your films, we listen to your music It's a big part of our lives by color. The way it's same. We watch, we're patch away with it. Right, but we don't understand all the class differences of the British accent. Right. I do. But yeah, I don't know. Somebody was on, I can't remember who we had on. They said one of the hardest words to say in the
而且这很难吗？我以前问过这个问题，美国口音对演员来说很难模仿吗？我觉得作为一个英国人，我们太……呃，被美国文化包围了。我们看你们的节目，看你们的电影，听你们的音乐。这是我们生活中的一大部分。因为颜色。方式也是一样的。我们看着，我们潜移默化地学会了。没错，但我们并不理解英国口音中所有的阶级差异。没错。我懂。但对，我不知道。之前有谁来过节目，我记不清是谁了。他们说，作为一个英国人，用美国口音说出的最难的词之一就是“murderer”（凶手）。Murderer。哦，那个挺难的。对，那可不容易。Murderer。Murderer。哦，见鬼。彼得·帕克。
with an American accent being a Brit is murderer. Murderer. Oh, that was good. Yeah, that's not easy. Murderer. Murderer. Oh, shit. Peter Parker.
我发现发“L”音很难。你能说“Arnold Palmer”（阿诺·帕尔默）吗？Arnold Palmer？看，这就很难。其实也没那么难。挺好的。Arnold Palmer。对。
I find L's difficult to say. Can you say Arnold Palmer? Arnold Palmer? See, that's hard. It's not really. It's good. Arnold Palmer. Yeah.
话说回来，作为演员，模仿口音对我来说会很难，因为我会把过多精力放在发音上而不是表演上。要把这两者分离开对你来说很难吗？对我而言，关于口音，我其实挺喜欢的，因为这就像是展现了你自身一个即时且不同的侧面。我觉得我演得最吃力的工作，反而是用我自己的
Now, do you get, do you get, it would be hard for me to do an accent as an actor because I would be thinking more about the pronunciation instead of the performance. Is that a hard thing for you to separate? I think for me, with accents, I like it because it's like an immediate, different side to yourself. I think the jobs where I've struggled the most is where I'm doing it in my own
口音去演。哦，真的吗？那让我觉得跟我真实的自我分离开得还不够彻底。你很难暂时抛开汤姆的身份。对，而且我不知道。我爸，你知道的，他是个喜剧演员，所以他从小就经常模仿各种口音，这是他非常擅长的。我们从小就听他在餐桌周围模仿各种口音。所以我很喜欢模仿口音。现在听起来你很有研究。你试过吗？你试过英国口音吗？我的意思是，偶尔来一点。对，但我肯定行。我知道效果会很好。不，你知道吗？就现在。我的意思是，我会的，我会说的。如果我试镜某个角色需要的话，我绝对会说，我不会对这个角色退缩。但我确实认为，有一些东西是需要去重点关注的。威利，你说你对英国的阶级差异以及各种不同的
accent. Oh really? It doesn't feel like enough of a departure from who I am. You have trouble leaving Tom. Yeah, and I don't know. My dad's, you know, he's a comic so he's always grown up doing accents is something he's really good at. We grew up with him doing it all, allways around the dinner table. So I love doing accents. Now it sounds like you have a theory. Have you done it? Have you tried a British accent? I mean, a bit here and there. Yeah, but I would know. I know it's going to be great. No, you know what? Right now. I mean, I would, I would do it. If I got cast in a part, I would definitely, I wouldn't, I wouldn't shy away from the part. But I do think there is, there is something to focus on. Will, you say you've got your hands around the class differences and all the different
英语口音了如指掌。我的确可以，是的，我能听出来。我能听出汤姆的口音，那就是……我猜你大概来自伦敦东部或东北部。我没猜错吧？伦敦西南部，不过确实是西南部。我的口音有点奇怪。我的发音听起来不太像我老家的人。
English. I can, yeah, I understand. Yeah, I could hear Tom's accent, which is, and I figured you were sort of like Eastern Northeast London. Am I right about that? Southwest London, but really that's Southwest. I have a bit of a weird accent. I don't really sound like where I'm from.
我的口音更像我身边聚在一起的人。我的大部分哥们儿都是那种地道的、像《浴血黑帮》里那样的人。对，这就是为什么你有点……对，你身上确实有一点那种感觉。就像是，只管把活儿干好，做好本职工作。对，没错，我尽量。我身上那种我从小长大的小资调调已经渐渐消失了。对，我的名字叫朗达。
I sound the people I'm surround myself with. Most of my mates are all facky, caught new blind. Yeah, that's why you have a little... Yeah, you have a little bit of that. Like, just get the job done, do the job. Yeah, right, I try. I've lost a sort of posh twang I grew up in. Yeah, my name is Ronda.
告诉我我不该怎么说话，亲爱的。我叫罗恩，我是个管道工。他是罗迪，是个水管工。你知道的，我们是热刺队的球迷。这其实一点也不差。而且因为我也是热刺球迷，你可能会以为我是你的……所以你会说，跟你混在一起的人，听起来你确实保持着一个非常正常的朋友圈，这对你来说并不算什么挣扎。你看上去是一个非常、非常正常的普通人。面对所有这些名气、突如其来的财富以及身边各种各样的人，你觉得这是你需要去对抗的事情吗？保持初心对你来说很难，还是说这很轻松？
Telling me how I shouldn't speak, darling. My name's Ron, I'm a placer. He's Rody's a plumber. You know, we follow the spurs. That's not bad at all. And also because I'm spurs as well, you'd think I'm your flundering. So you say, well, the people you surround yourself with, it does sound like you keep a very normal circle around you, and that that's not a struggle for you. You seem like a very, very normal guy. Is it something that you battle with all of this fame, unfortunate and permissive people around you? Is it tough for you to keep your head on your shoulders or does it come easy?
我不这么觉得。我觉得我父母在让我们保持清醒方面做得很好，尤其是在后来的日子里。我看到过很多朋友，一旦他们成功了，突然之间，你的父母就会指望你来养家糊口，或者维持整个家庭的开销之类的。而我很幸运，我的父母从来没有这样做过。
I don't think so. I think my parents did a good job of keeping us in check, especially later on. I think I've seen lots of friends where you become successful and all of a sudden, like, your parents rely on you to, you know, bring in the bread or keep the family going and stuff like that. And I've been really lucky that my parents have never done that.
他们一直都是我的父母。事情依然是……如果我爸有话要说，我还是会听他的，他绝不会藏着掖着。至于我的朋友们，他们都是打高尔夫的铁哥们儿，都是我的高尔夫球友。我们平时干的事就是打高尔夫。我在高尔夫球场上是不可能会惹上什么麻烦的。
They've always been my parents. It's still, you know, I listen to my dad if he's got something he wants to say, he won't shy away from it. And then my friends, they're all golf lads, they're all my golf mates. All we do is play golf. There's no way I've gotten into trouble on the golf course.
我前几天把我的7号铁给掰断了，这差不多就是我生活中最出格的不良行为了。我前几天甚至有一种想砸球杆的冲动，当时我还在想：我这是怎么了？发泄一下感觉会很好。对，当时能这么做感觉太棒了。更糟糕的是，那一杆我其实打得非常完美。我绝对是……打出了一记漂亮的微切球，
I snap my seven eye on the other day, which is kind of the extent of my bad behavior in life. And I felt like breaking a club the other day and I was like, what's going on with me? It would feel so good. Yeah, it was great to have this right now. And the thing that was even worse is I peered it. I absolutely like, I played a little buttery cut,
我真的很需要球稳稳地停在果岭上，结果它砸到了球车道上，然后“咚”的一声，我气得直接往后一仰，心想：靠！等等，等等，汤姆，当你拍《海啸奇迹》的时候，你多大？我想我当时刚满14岁。你当时懂得参演这样一部大电影的分量或重要性吗？
like I really need this to land soft, and I hit the car path, and it just, tuh, and I just, over the back of my head, I was like, bow! Wait, wait, so Tom, when you were in the impossible, how old were you in that? I think I was just turning 14. Did you understand like the weight or the gravity of being in a big movie like that?
还是说你根本没去想这些？其实我觉得我的年少无知真的是一件……对我来说太棒了，因为我当时太天真了。我把那些经历仅仅当成了夏令营。直到现在我年纪稍微大了一点，我才开始真正理解参演一部大电影或大制作剧集所带来的责任。我的电视剧就要播出了。对，对，对。
Or did you not even think about it? I actually think my youth was a real... It was great for me because I was so naive. I just looked at those experiences like a summer camp. It's only now that I'm a little bit older that I'm starting to really understand like the responsibility of being in a big film or a big show. I have my TV show come out. Right, right, right.
是的，是的，是的，对。那这是一部什么剧？跟我们讲讲这部剧吧。这部剧是一部名为《拥挤的房间》的诗选类剧集。这可以说是我的第一部……库尔德·戈尔德，对吧？哦，对，库尔德·戈尔兹。是个很有趣的酒吧。多棒的一个人啊。
Yes, yes, yes, right. And so what's the show? Tell us about this show. The show is an anthology series called The Cratted Room. It's sort of my first kind of a Cuban Goldman, right? Oh yeah, Cuban Golds. It's a funny bars. What a great guy.
我太喜欢他了。对，我们都很喜欢库尔德。老实说，和他合作简直是梦想成真。这算是我第一次真正意义上的制片经历，他真的对我悉心照顾，向我解释了如何正确行事的种种清规戒律。对，他简直是世界上最温柔、最聪明、
I love him so much. Yeah, we like Cuba. Honestly, like working with him was a dream come true. Like it was my first real time producing and he really took me under his wing and kind of explained to me the do's and the don'ts of how to do it properly. Yeah, he's just the sweetest, smartest,
经验最丰富的家伙。对。对他的赞美简直无以复加。他简直是世界上最温柔、最聪明、经验最丰富的家伙。对他的赞美简直无以复加。他太温柔了。当你从……当你接到《美国队长：内战》的工作时，你多大？因为那是第一部，对吧？你演了蜘蛛侠？对，那大概是在我18岁生日后10天。等等，所以那是你演蜘蛛侠之前……对。
most experienced guy. Yeah. Can't say enough of that. He's just the sweetest, smartest, most experienced guy. I can't say enough of that. He's so sweet. How old were you when you went from... When you got Captain America to the work? Because that was the first one, right? Were you played Spider-Man? Yeah, it was like 10 days after my 18th birthday. Wait, so that was before you did Spider-Man was... Yeah. Okay. Which was actually really great because it was somewhat like my audition for the general public. I got cast. There wasn't the greatest public feeling about me being cast. And then so before happened and for me it felt like my opportunity to like showcase what I could do in the character without having to take the weight of a standalone film. So I had a lot of experience in that movie.
好吧。这其实真的很好，因为这有点像是面向大众的一次公开试镜。我被选中了。大众对我的选角其实并没有什么太好的反响。所以《内战》上映之前，对我来说就像是一个机会，让我能够在不必承担一部独立电影全部票房压力的前提下，向大家展示我能把这个角色演成什么样。所以我从那部电影里积累了很多经验。
Why do you say it wasn't recent? It's like the heavy duty fans were just... I don't know. I tried not to read into it that much. I guess I wasn't the top pick. I don't know how, but the list of the final six people got out. And I definitely was at the bottom of the list. So I think being cast was like a bit of a shock to the system. But then when Civil War came out and people were really happy with it and they really enjoyed my performance and thought it was really, you know, it was unique and different.
你为什么说那不是最近的事？就像那些死忠粉们只是……我不知道。我尽量不去过多解读。我猜我当时并不是首选。我不知道怎么回事，最终入围的六人名单泄露了。而我绝对是排在名单的最底部。所以我觉得能被选上简直就像是对整个系统的一记惊雷。但后来《内战》上映了，大家对它的反响真的很好，他们真的很喜欢我的表演，觉得它确实……它是独特且与众不同的。
There was a big turnaround. So I was lucky to have Civil War. About the great Amy Pascal came in with her great taste and said, you know what, no, Tom is our guy. I love Amy Pascal. She's my mom away from home. What was your first experience, like meeting all the other Avenger to Actors? Were you starstruck? What was that like coming in first day at work?
所以舆论有了一个巨大的转变。我很幸运能参演《内战》。伟大的艾米·帕斯卡尔带着她卓越的品味走了进来，斩钉截铁地说：“你知道吗，不，汤姆就是我们要找的人。”我爱艾米·帕斯卡尔。她就像我异乡的母亲。你第一次见到所有其他复仇者联盟的演员时，是什么样的体验？你当时有追星的感觉吗？第一天去上班是什么情况？
I think it's that interesting thing where you just realize that everyone's actors wearing crazy costumes sitting on the same set chairs and the same Atlanta food, you know? Like, it was obviously really amazing and I was 18, a huge fan of those shows. So it was super exciting. I think Downey, yeah, you had to put up with Downey. He really does a good job of like setting the tone.
我觉得那种感觉很有趣，你会突然意识到每个人都只是穿着滑稽服装、坐在同样的片场椅子上、吃着同样的亚特兰大剧组盒饭的演员，你知道吗？这当然真的很神奇，而且我当时18岁，是那些节目的超级粉丝。所以这超级激动人心。我觉得小罗伯特·唐尼，对，你得忍受唐尼。他在树立基调方面真的做得很好。
Oh, it does a good job. Of like how people should behave. He's on time. He professionally knows his lines. He knows everyone's name. He's respectful. I would you would you agree with me on this and the guys might too. Downey's the funniest motherfucker around. Yeah. Right. I mean, how fucking funny is downey? I love. He's the most frustrating scene partner out there. I can't help it. I'm not saying anyone like him. You sit down, you get sent the pages, I write stuff,
哦，他真的做得很好。关于大家应该如何行为举止。他总是准时到场。他非常专业，台词背得滚瓜烂熟。他知道每个人的名字。他非常尊重他人。你会……你会同意我的看法吗，伙计们可能也会这么觉得？唐尼是周围最搞笑的混蛋。对。没错。我的意思是，唐尼他妈的到底有多搞笑？我太喜欢了。他是片场最让人沮丧的对手演员。我忍不住。我不是说有谁像他一样。你坐下来，拿到剧集页面的台词，我写了自己的东西，
I try and come up with something funny, I'm trying to bring my flavor to, you know, sometimes he stale stuff. And you spit out your joke on set, you think that's going to land, that's so good, and he just uses your joke to set up his joke that's going to brush off the dome and you're like, that's so irritating. I love that. He is the best. Did he fly? Didn't he come in and like a helicopter or something or on the first?
我试图想出一些有趣的东西，我试图把我的个人特色带进去，你知道的，有时他会把事情搞砸。你在片场说出你的笑话，你以为那个梗一定会响，效果会非常好，结果他直接把你的笑话当成铺垫，用来抖他自己的包袱，把你的风头全抢光，你会觉得：这真的太烦人了。我太喜欢这样了。他是最棒的。他是不是坐直升机来的？他第一天来的时候是不是坐直升机什么的？
Yeah, he did, yeah. We were, it was six of us, six kids that were auditioning. It's the weirdest kind of meeting I've ever had. Like, we're all sitting down, having lunch and like, eyeing each other up. And I'm like, I could probably take you lot physically. I don't know like how we could go in an acting thing. And then, and then, down he, yeah, he flew over us
对，他是坐直升机来的。我们当时有六个人，六个正在试镜的孩子。那是我经历过最奇怪的一次见面。就像，我们都坐在一起吃午饭，互相打量着对方。我当时想：从身体条件上讲，我可能分分钟能打趴你们这群人。但我不知道我们在演技上会怎么样。然后，然后，唐尼，对，他从我们头顶
in his helicopter, he landed on the, the helipad next door to the stage, he drove over. That's not helpful, you're already nervous. And then here comes your scene partner in a helicopter. I know. I'm such a hopeless optimist, though, like as soon as I saw the helicopter, I was like, I'm getting this part
坐着直升机飞过，降落在舞台隔壁的直升机坪上，然后开车过来。这可真没用，你本来就已经够紧张了。结果你的对手演员竟然是坐直升机登场的。我知道。不过我这人是个无可救药的乐观主义者，我一看到直升机就想：我肯定能拿到这个角色，试镜结束后我要跟他一起坐直升机飞走。我当时真的觉得事情就会这样发展。试镜进展得非常顺利，我觉得自己表现得很棒，结果大约七周时间里杳无音讯。什么？到了那个时候，你差不多就会觉得，算了吧，你已经放弃了，我没被选上。结果他们又叫我去进行第二次试镜。
and I'm flying away with him after the audition. I genuinely was like, this is that's how the day's gonna go. The audition went so well, I thought it was great, didn't hear anything for like seven weeks. What? At that point, you sort of go, you let it go, I didn't get it. Call me back for a second audition.
我和克里斯·埃文斯进行了一次银幕测试，那是一场打斗测试。而且，你知道的，我有体操背景，所以我当时想：我他妈的要超常发挥。我要把每一个空翻、侧空翻、后空翻，凡是我能做出来的动作全都使出来，一定要拿下这个角色。我回家后，又是大约四五个星期没有任何消息，然后有一天我在刷Instagram，漫威发布了一张蜘蛛侠的照片，上面写着：如果你想知道下一任蜘蛛侠是谁，请访问我们的网站。于是我点进了他们的网站。你当时心想：我想知道下一任是谁。我就想：对，但问题是，我觉得肯定不是我，因为他们至少会更有
I did a screen test with Chris Evans, which was like a fight test. And, you know, I have a gymnastics background, so I was like, I'm fucking going above and beyond. I'm doing every flip, side flip, back flip, whatever I can do to get this part. I went home, heard nothing for like another four or five weeks, and then I was scrolling through Instagram, and Marvel had posted a picture of Spider-Man and said like, if you want to find out who the next Spider-Man is, go to our website. So I went to their website. And you're like, I want to know who the next one is. I was like, yeah, but the thing is, I was like, it's obviously not me because they'd have more
礼貌，而不是直接发在网上。他们会打电话通知你的。我上了网，看了头条新闻，上面写着我的名字。为什么？我记得我当时“啪”地合上电脑，心想：这不可能是真的。而且这也是索尼遭到黑客攻击的那段时间前后。所以我当时想：这里面肯定有什么猫腻。这绝对是恶作剧。然后一个小时后，我接到了工作室的电话。我接到了索尼的电话。
respect than just putting it online. They would call you. I went online, I read the headline, it said my name. Why? I remember like shutting my computer and being like, this can't be real. And this was also right around the time that Sony had been hacked. So I was like, there's something going on here. This is the right way. And then an hour later, I got a call from the studio. I got a call from Sony.
我接到了我的经纪人的电话。他们说：我们不知道这消息是怎么泄露的，但我们已经选定你了。祝你好运。我们真的很兴奋。但这消息是发在漫威官网上的吗？对，所以我猜他们只是想抢在泄露之前提前官宣。
I got a call from my agents. Like, we don't know how this has been leaked, but we've cast you. Good luck. Like, we're really excited. But it was on the Marvel website? Yeah, so I think they just try to get ahead of the leak and make the announcement.
然后我在后来的每个采访里基本上都说，这就是我得知消息的方式，所以他们的保密计划算是彻底泡汤了。呃-huh。不过，对，这真的很棒。话说回来，你当时的兴奋程度肯定爆表了，但你对未来的预期，和你现在实际经历的生活是一致的吗？
And then in every interview, basically said, that's how I found out, so that didn't work out for them. Uh-huh. But yeah, it was great. Now, what was your level of excitement must have been through the roof, obviously, but was your anticipation of what was to come accurate with what you now have lived?
就像，你当时能预见到这一切会发生吗？还是说现实比你想象的更好或更糟？现实要好得多。我根本……我完全无法预料事情会这么有趣，而且回报会如此丰厚。我觉得人们对那种类型的电影往往带有某种刻板印象。是的，但我经历过很多次那种情况。都是你的错。
Like, did you see exactly what was coming or has it been better or worse? It's been so much better. I couldn't, I could not have anticipated it being as fun as it was and how rewarding it's been. I think there's a stigma with those types of films. Yeah, but I've had a lot of that. You're a fault.
你可能真的很享受这一切。你一直是个很棒的领头羊。你从中找到了很多乐趣。而且你为自己和周围的每个人都创造了一个很好的环境。这会为后续的发展带来很多积极的成果。谢谢。我很感激。对，我也这么觉得。而且我读到过，对吧？是不是真的像传闻那样，你从小就是个蜘蛛侠迷，这会为后续的发展带来很多积极的成果，对吧？谢谢。
You probably have just really enjoyed it. You've been a great leader. You've had fun with it. And you've created a great environment for yourself and everybody else. That yields a lot of good stuff afterwards. Well, thank you. I appreciate that. Yeah, I think so. And I read, didn't I? Isn't it true that you've been a Spider-Man fans that yields a lot of good stuff afterwards, right? Well, thank you.
我很感激。对，我也这么觉得。而且我读到过，对吧？是不是真的像传闻那样，你小时候就是个蜘蛛侠迷？全在我身上。我妈留了数不清的戏服，全都是从来没洗过的，
I appreciate that. Yeah, I think so. And I read, didn't I? Isn't it true that you've been a Spider-Man fans and you were a kid, right? On me. Like, my mom has got countless costumes that have never been washed
全是我大概四岁的时候死活不肯脱下来时的衣服。我甚至还从双层床上往下跳之类的。我当时简直痴迷到了极点。而且事实上我大概15岁时在红毯上接受过一次采访。当时有人问：如果你能扮演任何超级英雄，你想演谁？
of when I was like a four-year-old kid for refusing to take it off. A really new bounce-in off of the bunk beds and stuff like that. I was obsessed. And there's actually an interview of me when I was maybe 15 on a red carpet. And someone said, like, if you could play any superhero, who would you play?
这大概是事情发生七年前的事。或者也许没那么久。我说过：我希望能接替安德鲁·加菲尔德扮演蜘蛛侠。我觉得那会是我的梦想。然后他妈的梦想真的成真了。太疯狂了。那是我一生中最疯狂的一天。
This is like seven years before it happened. Or maybe not as long as that. And I said, I'd love to play Spider-Man after Andrew Garfield. Like that would be my dream. And then fucking came true. That's crazy. Crazy is day of my life.
我简直不敢相信。而现在你继续前进，除了那些之外，你还拍了一些非常酷的戏剧作品。能够通过穿插一些截然不同的作品来规划你的一年或几年时间，并且和你的团队一起把这些事情都妥善安排好，这感觉一定很棒吧？你的目标就是要在所有这些事情中找到真正的平衡吗？这倒不一定是我特别刻意去想的事情。我只是……
I couldn't believe it. And now you've gone on, you've done some really cool dramatic stuff in addition to that as well. That must be nice to kind of construct your year or a few years by, you know, sort of weaving in stuff that is very different from it and working with your folks to get all that stuff squared away. Is that your goal is to try to find a real balance with all that stuff? It's not necessarily something I particularly think about. I just... Yeah, man, not everybody's a psycho. Thinking about braiding everything in, you know what I mean?
老兄，并不是每个人都是精神病，把所有事情都规划得面面俱到，你知道我的意思吗？我觉得《拥挤的房间》对我来说，是的，这是一个挑战，而且它与众不同。我觉得我和库尔德，你知道他是什么样的人。他是一个了不起的人。我觉得这部剧有一个非常棒且至关重要的内核。我只是觉得……我不知道，我当时觉得有一种使命感，想要一头扎进去，接受这个挑战，看看效果会怎么样。我太喜欢这样了。
I think the crowded room for me, like, yeah, it's a challenge and it's different. I think me and Kiva, you know, you know what he's like. He is an amazing guy. I think the show has an amazing message that's really important. And I just felt, I don't know, I felt compelled to kind of jump into it and accept the challenge and see how it goes. I love that.
我不知道。我真的不知道我接下来要做什么。我已经休假一年了。我今年完全没有工作。老实说，我这段时间一直待在家裡，每天都在打高尔夫球。你这是应得的。而且你现在拥有如此庞大的粉丝群体，简直是巨大。
And I don't know. I don't really know what I'm gonna do next. I have taken the year off. I haven't worked at all this year. I've just been at home, honestly, just playing golf every day. You deserve it. And now you have such a massive following, just huge.
我的意思是，这……你有没有觉得，这听起来像是个老套的问题，但我绝对是真心实意的。你是否会感到压力，或者觉得有某种责任去成为一个榜样——虽然你并没有主动要求承担这个？但它就这么发生了，还是说你会想：这不是我，我没有要求过这个，别把我当成榜样，我只是个演员；亦或是你会欣然接受它？
I mean, it's, and do you feel, it sounds like a cheesy question, but I really mean it. Do you feel pressure or any kind of responsibility to be kind of like a role model, not that you asked for that? But it kind of just happened, or do you just go, that's not me, I didn't ask for it, and don't look at me as a role model, I'm just an actor, or do you embrace it?
我要说一件真正让我感到压力山大的事情，那就是我有严重的阅读障碍，所以每次我在Instagram上发动态时，我都得找大概三个人帮我仔细校对、审阅我写的内容。这真的、真的很让我焦虑，因为这是发给很多人的，你可不想让自己看起来像个白痴，对吧？就像我的帖子一样。审阅我写的东西。哦，哇。这真的、真的很让我焦虑，因为这是发给很多人的，你可不想让自己看起来像个白痴。
I'd say something that really does stress me out, is that I am so severely dyslexic, that when I post on Instagram for something, I have to get like three people to proof, read, what I've written, it really, really stresses me out, because it goes out to a lot of people, and you don't look like an idiot, you know? Like my post. read what I've written. Oh wow. It really, really stresses me out because it goes out to a lot of people and you don't look like an idiot.
没错。就像我发的东西。不，我想我能理解这种责任。我很幸运，我的生活中能有赞达亚这样的人。和身处同样处境的人谈恋爱是一件很有趣的事。对。你们可以分享彼此的经历和诸如此类的事情，
Right. Like my person. No, I guess I understand the responsibility. I'm lucky that I have someone like Zendair in my life. It's interesting being in a romantic relationship with someone that is in the same boat as you. Yeah. You can share your experiences and all that sort of stuff
而这绝对是千金难买的宝贵财富。是的，确实如此。我想知道，因为你现在拍了那么多大电影，经历过无数庞大的宣传巡回。我记得说到这个，我们采访一开始就提到过，你今年27岁，我当时也是27岁。那是我的演艺生涯中第一次面临“我得做多少次采访，去哪里，干什么”的困惑。
and that's worth it's weight and gold. Yeah, for sure. I wonder because now you've done so many big movies in massive press junkets. And I remember speaking of, we started the interview saying, you're 27 years old, I was 27. And that's when I first was like, I have to do how many interviews and go where and what.
所有的宣传造势以及长达数小时的媒体联访——顺便说一句，这本身就是一门艺术——但是，当你第一次看到需要你配合的宣传工作量时，那是什么感觉？你当时觉得……而且你喜欢做这些吗，因为你其实很擅长？对，谢谢。对，我总是尽量保持
And it's like all of that press and the hours of the press junkets, which is an art in and of itself, by the way, but what about the first time you saw the amount of press required of you? Was that like, and do you like doing, because you're really good at it? Yeah, thanks. Yeah, I just always try and like,
微笑挥手，永远不要让别人看出你内心的真实感受。对，对，对。就像这已经是你当天第60个采访了，然后有个人走进来问你：“你睡在哪边床上的？”你心里只想说：滚你妈的蛋！你为什么想知道这个？离我远点。
smile and wave and never let them know how you really feel. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Like you're almost 60th in the interview of the day and someone comes in and they're like, what's out of the bed do you sleep on? And it's like, what the fuck off? Why do you wanna know that? Leave me alone.
对，我的意思是，这也是个布满地雷的领域，对吧？因为你做了太多采访，我敢打赌，为了自娱自乐，你大概会忍不住在这里或那里稍微改变一下你的回答。但随后你可能会不小心聊到一些比你原本预想的要更有料的话题，然后媒体就抓住了这个头条。而这就是他们最喜欢利用的东西。这正是前几天发生在我身上的事。我在去年1月戒了酒。顺便说一句，恭喜你戒酒成功，
Yeah, I mean, it's a bit of a minefield too, right? Because you do so much of it and I'll bet you probably wanna change your answer a little bit here and there just to keep yourself entertained. But then you might get into something that's a little bit spicier than you even mean to say and then now they've got a headline. And that's the thing they grab. And that's the thing that happened to me the other day. So I gave up drinking of January of last year. And by the way, congrats on your sobriety and
并且恭喜你如此公开地谈论这件事，这帮助了非常非常多的人。所以我可以解脱了。这太棒了，老兄。谢谢。对。所以我戒酒的原因有很多，但其实最主要的还是因为我想休息一段时间。对。而在经历那段休息期的过程中，这是我做过最难的事情。当时我就想：哦，也许我该更严肃地看待这件事。并把假期延长。最终我把戒酒期限延长到了我的生日——6月1日。
congrats on speaking so publicly about it and it helps lots and lots of people. So I could free up. That's a great, bud. Thank you. Yeah. So I gave up for a multitude of reasons, but really just because I wanted to take a break. Yeah. And in taking that break, it was the hardest thing I'd ever done. And was like, oh, maybe I should look at this a little bit more seriously. And elongate the break. Eventually I took it to my birthday, June 1st.
等我坚持了六个月之后，我感觉状态好极了，以至于我心想：我以后可能再也不会喝酒了。哇。但前几天我做了一个大约持续一个小时的采访，其中我谈到了自己戒酒的经历。然后在采访进行了大约45分钟后，我开了一个玩笑，说我在片场情绪崩溃过，甚至想把头发剃光。因为我在拍这部剧时发型实在是太疯狂了。结果那篇文章的头条居然是：
And by the time I done six months, I felt so amazing that I was like, I don't think I'll ever drink ever again. Wow. But I did an interview the other day for like an hour where I spoke about giving up drinking. And then about 45 minutes later, I told a joke about having a meltdown on set and wanting to cut my hair off. Because my hair was so crazy for this show. And the headline of the article was,
汤姆·霍兰德在片场情绪崩溃后宣布戒酒。这就好比……这根本不是那么回事……我知道。这简直让人只想直接罢工不干了。我们在步步高升，特雷斯。我知道，全完了。对。
Tom Holland gave up drinking after having a meltdown on set. And it's like, that's not even... I know. It makes you just want to just stop. We're moving up, Trace. I know, it's all done. Yeah.
好吧，这真的很艰难。宣传可不是闹着玩的。这确实很棘手。你必须有所选择。好吧，永远别剪你的头发。你有一头好头发。对，这真的很艰难。没错。这确实很棘手。你得……你得……你得有所选择。好吧，永远别剪你的头发。你有一头好头发。对，确实如此。谢谢。我挺喜欢这种胡扯的。我爸前几天——杰森，我爸说他觉得……他说：杰森·贝特曼绝对戴了假发。在英国俚语里，“syrup”意思是假发。他戴了假发，是个大假发。我说：
Well, it's really tough. It's not that spread. It's tricky. You got to pick and choose. Well, don't ever cut your hair. You got good hair. Yeah, it's really tough. That's right. It's tricky. You got it. You got it. You got to pick and choose. Well, don't ever cut your hair. You got good hair. Yeah, you do. Thank you. I like this bullshit. My dad the other day Jason was saying my dad said he said Jason Bateman. He's definitely got a syrupy knee and a syrupy in England means a wig. He's a syrupy and big wig. And I said,
不，我不这么认为，爸。我觉得那纯粹就是他自己的头发。我爸显然有点酸，因为我爸快要秃顶了。他当时就说：“那个杰森·贝特曼，他绝对戴了假发。”我说：“不，爸，我真的觉得那就是他自己的头发。”对，而且杰森，永远……那是他自己的头发，这简直太惊人了。他连一根白发都没有。对，人们觉得要么是植发，要么是染发，或者两者皆有，但其实根本不是。这就是运气。你只能说这全是运气。人们会觉得要么是植发，要么是染发，或者两者皆有，但其实根本不是。这就是运气。你只能说这全是运气。话说回来，汤姆·霍兰德，我们占用了你太多时间了。你太棒了。很高兴认识你。我是认真的，而且这么久以来……
no, I don't think so, dad. I think that's just his hair. My dad's obviously bitter because my dad bests of losing his hair. And he was like, that Jason Bateman, he's definitely wearing a syrup. I said, no, Dad, I'm genuinely thinking that just his hair. Yeah, no, plus Jason, never, there's this hair, which is astounding. He doesn't have a gray hair on him. Yeah, people think it's either it's plugs or it's color or both, and it's, it's just not. It's luck. It's just all you've got luck. It's going to be think it's either it's plugs or it's color or both and it's just not it's luck. It's just all you look It's gonna be it's gonna be thinned out Tom Holland, we've taken up way too much time. You're awesome. It's so nice to meet you I mean it's just and for so long and and and and it's like you emit exactly what you are exactly who I would hope
你完美地展现了你原本的样子，正是我希望你会成为的那种人——最酷、最接地气、最随和。这完全符合我们的预期。继续保持，老兄！对，老兄，你太牛了。这是一档非常有趣且出色的节目。我和我弟弟一直都在听你们的播客。所以能来到这里对我来说是一种荣幸。我们应该去打几场高尔夫，你也一定要来。
You'd be just like the coolest grounded nicest. It's exactly what we've heard. Keep it up, buddy. Yeah, man, I'm killing it. It's such a fun and a show. My brother and I were always listening to you guys. So it's an honor for me to be here. And we should play some golf and sure you should come.
你一直都这么酷、脚踏实地而且人超级好。这完全就是我们听说的那样。加油，兄弟。对啊，伙计，我表现得太棒了。这节目真的太有趣了。我和我弟弟总是听你们的节目。所以能来到这里对我来说是一种荣幸。我们应该去打高尔夫球，你肯定也该来。
Oh, come on, John. You know what, they'll count me in for the poker. I love poker. Okay, don't. If you're in London, we have a poker game, the first weekend of every month, if you fancy it, it's a lot of fun. I'm gonna hit you up, Tom, when I come to England
哦，得了吧，约翰。你知道吗，他们打扑克会算上我一个的。我超爱扑克。好吧，别这样。如果你在伦敦，我们每个月的第一个周末都有个扑克局，如果你有兴趣的话，非常有趣。汤姆，我去英国的时候一定联系你
and we're gonna play. For 100%. And we'll go watch a football game. Yeah, fantastic. Wicked. Thank you, Tommy. I get to now call you. Absolutely.
咱们到时候玩。百分之百。我们还要去看场足球比赛。太棒了。好极了。谢谢你，汤米。我现在可以这么叫你了。当然可以。
Thank you, buddy. Have a great rest of the day. Thanks, pal. I appreciate it. Thank you guys. Bye, buddy. Oh, nice. Yeah. What a great guy. I said it. Thank you guys. Bye, buddy. Bye, bye. How nice. Yeah. What a great guy.
谢谢你，兄弟。今天剩下的时候过得愉快。谢谢，老兄。我很感激。谢谢你们。再见，兄弟。哦，太好了。是的。真是个好人。我刚才最后说了。谢谢你们。再见，兄弟。拜拜。多好啊。是的。真是个好人。
I said it at the end there. He's so wonderful. I didn't know that about his drinking. That's great. Good for him. Yeah, yeah. I wonder if that's tough with all the living and basically a frat house. I wonder if they're all not drinking too. That could be tough.
我最后的时候说过了。他太棒了。我以前不知道他戒酒了。太好了。真替他高兴。对，对。我就想，住在基本上就是兄弟会那样的环境里，这会不会很难？我想他们是不是也都不喝酒？那可能会挺难的。
I'm always kind of astounded too when somebody like him who's so young and got such big, massive things happen for him in his career when he's so young. They always carry themselves so confidently and like, you know, not to repeat the Jason Bateman thing over and over again, but the sexy indifference like that. They always have this like swagger that's like, yeah, I'm good if we do it,
每当看到像他这样这么年轻、事业上就有如此巨大成就的人时，我总是感到有点惊讶。他们总是表现得非常自信，而且，你知道的，虽然不想一遍又op地重复杰森·贝特曼的话，但那种性感而冷漠的劲儿……他们总是自带一种风范，好像在说，“行吧，做不做都无所谓”，
I'm good if we don't. Right. Like this like and and it's a confidence thing that I never had at that age. It's I don't know how and and so many people you have it you had it too Jay when you were younger too. They all have this like thing where I don't know how they how they learn that or where they get that from. Well mine mine was I bought mine and should have been renting it because it, it, it went away for me. And it was a, it was a, an uncomfortable correction when, you know, I had some, some quiet times. And it was like, oh, I don't feel so confident anymore. I'm no longer indifferent. I really want it back. And it hurt my ability to even get it back because now I'm walking into auditions desperate
“不做我也挺好”。对吧？就像这种感觉，这是一种我在那个年纪从来没有过的自信。我不知道怎么……而且很多人都有，杰伊，你年轻时也有过。他们都有这样一种特质，我不知道他们是怎么学会的，或者这是从哪来的。嗯，我的嘛……我那是买来的，本来该租的，因为它……它对我来说消失了。那是一次……那是一次很不舒服的调整，你知道的，当我经历了一段低谷期之后。感觉就像是，哦，我不再那么自信了。我不再那么冷漠了。我真的很想把它找回来。这甚至损害了我重新获得它的能力，因为现在我走进试听间时充满渴望
and really wanting something. And you start squeezing the puppy and it starts to choke out. Yeah. I squeeze the puppy and sometimes it chokes out. Uh oh. Oh, okay. Tom Holland was so great, so great to have him on.
并且非常想要某样东西。然后你开始捏那只小狗，它就开始窒息了。是的。我捏了那只小狗，有时它会窒息。噢哦。哦，好的。汤姆·霍兰德太棒了，很高兴他能来。
Love that Tom Holland. He's a, I don't mean this disrespectfully. He's a great kid. Great kid, you know. Well, because he looks, he wouldn't, I think he knows it. I used to be on my age. I'll tell you. It looks like, you know, it looks thin, you know, it might be, he maybe, he should have
我真喜欢那个汤姆·霍兰德。他是个——我这话没有不尊重他的意思。他是个好孩子。真的是个好孩子，你知道的。嗯，因为他看起来，他不会，我想他自己也知道。我以前也是我这个年纪。我跟你说。看起来，你知道，看起来很瘦，你知道，他可能，也许他应该
a sandwich or maybe just order a nice big juicy rib. Bye. Bye. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday, Squirtle.
吃个三明治，或者点一块美味多汁的肋排。再见。再见。杰尼龟，生日快乐。杰尼龟，生日快乐。杰尼龟，生日快乐。杰尼龟，生日快乐。杰尼龟，生日快乐。
Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday. Happy birthday. Happy birthday, Squirtle. Happy birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy Birthday! Happy SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granterry. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondri app. I'm Leon Nefak, the host of Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn. And I'm Jay Smooth, a hip-hop journalist and cultural commentator.
杰尼龟，生日快乐。生日快乐。生日快乐。杰尼龟，生日快乐。生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！生日快乐！SmartLess 是由罗布·阿姆茹尔夫、贝内特·巴巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里 100% 有机手工制作的。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，您可以在任何收听播客的地方收听，也可以现在就在 Amazon Music 上提前收听，或者通过在 Apple Podcasts 或 Wondri 应用中订阅 Wondry Plus 来提前收听无广告版。我是莱昂·内法克，《Fiasco》的主持人兼《Slow Burn》的联合创作者。我是杰·斯穆斯，一名嘻哈记者和文化评论员。
Michael Jackson was accused of child molestation for the first time in 1993. Our new podcast Think Twice, Michael Jackson, is the story of what came before and what came after. Throughout the podcast, we explore what makes Michael Jackson seemingly uncancelable. And we dig into the complicated feelings so many of us have when we hear Billie Jean at the grocery store. Through dozens of original interviews with people who watched the story unfold firsthand, think twice as an attempt to reconcile our conflicted emotions about Michael Jackson, the man with our deep-seated love of his art.
迈克尔·杰克逊于 1993 年首次被指控猥亵儿童。我们的新播客《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》讲述了之前和之后的故事。在整个播客中，我们探讨了是什么让迈克尔·杰克逊看起来似乎无法被“取消”。我们深入探讨了我们在杂货店听到《比利简》时许多人心中产生的复杂情感。通过对亲历这一事件的人们进行的数十次原创采访，《三思》试图将我们对迈克尔·杰克逊这个人的矛盾情感与我们对他的艺术的根深蒂固的热爱调和起来。
Listen to think twice, Michael Jackson, wherever you get your podcast, or you can binge the entire series at free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music App. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》，无论你在哪里获取播客，或者你可以在 Amazon Music 应用上无广告、不间断地一口气听完整部系列节目。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。